So, ich bin am Start.
Ich weiß ernsthaft nicht, warum ich da gerade Wordpad für einen Text aufgemacht habe.
Brauchst du unbedingt RGB?
Ne, Gegenteil ist der Fall.
Ich habe überhaupt kein Problem damit, wenn das nicht RGB ist.
Ich mache RGB meistens aus.
Wobei ich sagen muss...
Warte mal, ich mache mal Kirby ein bisschen leiser.
Ja, wobei ich sagen muss, ich bin jetzt auch nicht total abgeneigt, wenn die RGB hat.
Weil die K95, die hat auch RGB und ich habe die lange Zeit ausgehabt.
Und jetzt habe ich es einfach an, sodass es leicht blau-gelb so rum vor sich hin wavet.
Das Keyboard, das hatte ich mir schon vor einer Weile angeguckt.
Das hat mir nicht gefallen, weil es glaube ich kein NumBlock hatte, oder?
NumBlock, ich will NumBlock.
NumBlock.
Ich will einen NumBlock haben.
Okay, das hatte ich mir vor einer Weile schon mal angeguckt.
Und dann habe ich mir eine Ducky One Skyline bestellt und...
Guck mal, hier mit dem Knopf oben dran.
Eine Ducky One Skyline für die Arbeit bestellt und ich habe mir für der Heimat eine K95 Platinum bestellt.
Gefällt mir eigentlich ganz gut.
Muss ja nicht durchgehend Rainbow geplinkt sein, ja genau.
Wobei so ein bisschen RGB ist schon nicht verkehrt.
So, mal Kirby.
Mal kurz ein bisschen...
Wir machen jetzt entspannende Nintendo-Musik-Winter-Mix.
Das ist...
Das ist The Secret of Mana, das höre ich sofort.
Warum ist...
Warum ist der Sound so laut eigentlich gerade?
Ah.
So.
Jetzt ist der Sound ein bisschen leiser.
Dann einfach so.
So ist gut.
Ja Leute, also ich muss euch ja mal erzählen, wegen der Tastatur, ne?
Und zwar gestern, nachdem ich den Stream ausgemacht habe.
Ich habe hier immer so eine...
So eine große...
So ein null...
Null...
Was ist denn das eigentlich?
Ein 0,5er Glas?
Also eigentlich ist es ein 0,5er Plastikbecher, ja.
Oh, Plastik!
Oh Gott.
Die Umwelt.
Ich habe Plastikbecher.
Also ich habe hier so 0,5er Plastikbecher stehen und da habe ich immer ganz Noob-Style Wasser mit ein bisschen Orangensaft drin.
Also hier Leute.
Excellent.
Exquisite.
Wasser mit Orangensaft, ja.
So.
Und...
Die Sache ist die, ich habe...
Ich bin da irgendwie ein bisschen rumgelaufen, so habe ich was getrunken, beim Abstellen habe ich halt ein bisschen gesaut.
Nicht viel.
Du hast dir letztens Nudelsuppe auf die Tastatur gekippt.
Oh, das ist schlecht.
Das ist schlecht.
Wobei, ja es ist schlecht, aber Hauptsache schön trocknen lassen alles.
Naja, zumindest nachdem ich dann erstmal geisteslos...
...gegenwärtig mit quasi Overwatch Top 500 Reflexes, habe ich dann quasi erstmal einen Lappen auf die Tastatur geschmissen und dann hat auch alles wieder funktioniert.
Das einzige was passiert ist, ist die RGB-Beleuchtung ist instant ausgegangen, aber ich habe es nochmal abgestöpselt, wieder eingestöpselt in die Tastatur und dann ging es auch wieder.
So, und was ich dann aber festgestellt habe ist, also bei der hier jetzt, was ich dann festgestellt habe ist,
die Q-Taste ging nicht, aber ihr seht, Q geht wieder.
Und gestern Abend, als ich den Rechner da ausgemacht habe, habe ich mir gedacht, hoffentlich ist die Tastatur kaputt.
Weil da kann ich mir was Neues kaufen.
Weil ich mag die Tastatur nicht.
Und leider, wie ihr seht, geht das Q wieder.
Aber ich habe jetzt festgestellt, manch andere Taste klebt ein bisschen.
Dank dem Orangene.
Dank dem Orangensaft.
So, und deswegen habe ich mir gedacht, ich habe jetzt die Auswahl, ich könnte das sauber machen, oder aber ich könnte mir eine neue Tastatur kaufen, weil ich die Tastatur eh kacke finde.
Also mal zur Erklärung, das haben wir auf Twitter auch, ich meine, ich habe es ja auf Twitter geschrieben im Endeffekt.
Also was mir an der Tastatur nicht gefällt, ist folgendes.
Erstens, dass die schon seit fast Anfang an doppelte Tastenanschläge hat.
Das macht mich verrückt.
Ja, Maximilianus, das erzähle ich gerade, weil das haben viele gefragt.
Du bist nicht der Einzige, der das wissen wollte.
Also das ist das Erste.
Dass sie fast seit Anfang an doppelte Tastaturanschläge hatten.
Das macht mich echt verrückt.
Wenn du irgendwas copy und pastest und auf einmal ist es dreimal drin und sowas.
Ihr habt es im Stream schon öfters gesehen.
So.
Und kann man RMA'en?
Ja, habe ich ja nicht gemacht.
Ich glaube, jetzt mit Orangensaft kann ich sie nicht mehr RMA'en.
Ups.
Wollte da gar nicht die IP oben rein machen.
So.
Das Nächste ist, was mir auch nicht gefällt, dass sie ein komisches Layout hat.
Das muss ich jetzt ein bisschen erklären.
Auf Twitter kann man das immer so schlecht erklären, weil man macht nicht so viele Zeichen.
Und das ist auch gut, das macht das Twitter aus.
Die haben meine Rahmentastatur auch RMA'en.
Ernsthaft?
Ich will die Tastatur aber eigentlich gar nicht mehr, weil die gefällt mir auch aus anderen Aspekten nicht.
Mir gefällt das Layout nicht.
Und zwar, das ist auch ein Problem, was ich seit Anfang an hatte.
Da haben wir mal ein schönes Bild von der Tastatur, so richtig schön in groß vielleicht.
Und zwar, von Anfang an hatte ich das Problem.
Ja, hier sieht man es gut.
Und ich dachte mir, ich komme damit irgendwie klar.
Das Problem, was ich mit dem Layout habe, ich meine jetzt nicht, dass es eine Quertstastatur ist,
oder in dem Fall die englische Variante.
Ne, was mir nicht gefällt an der Tastatur ist, das Control.
Also.
Und der G6-Makro-Key, die liegen so komisch beieinander, dass man nie auf die Schnelle,
ich meine, ja, die haben ein bisschen andere Texturierung, ja, es ist nicht so, dass man das gar nicht merken würde,
aber ich bin nicht in der Lage, da schnell zuzuhandeln.
Gibt es da nochmal ein richtig großes Bild?
Richtig, ja, sehr schön von oben, da kann man nämlich ein bisschen ranzoomen.
Genau.
Guckt, ihr seht, die haben ja schon andere Textur auf den...
Auf den Buttons, aber man merkt das nicht.
Man merkt das nicht.
Doch, hat sie, hat sie.
Aber man merkt das nicht richtig.
Und dementsprechend, ich habe das so gefühlsmäßig drin, dass ich meine Control-Taste am unteren,
beziehungsweise am linken Rand, wo die Keys aufhören, suche.
Und ich will nicht wissen, wie oft ich auf G6 gedrückt habe, anstatt auf Control.
Die Textur ist zwar ein bisschen anders, aber ganz ehrlich, Leute,
wenn ihr irgendwas macht...
Wenn ihr irgendwas macht in einem Game, hier, schöner AD-Spam oder sowas,
und dann wollt ihr einfach irgendwie in Deckung gehen, irgendwie Control-Spam und...
Ey, ich habe gedacht, ich gewöhne mich da dran, aber ich hatte...
Ich habe mich nie hundertprozentig dran gewöhnt.
Einfach G6 auf Control-Spam, ja, könnte man auch, aber das ist auch keine wirklich gute Lösung,
weil ich dann öfters auch mal mit dem Finger hier dazwischen lande.
Ich bin dann auch so ein Noob, der den kleinen Finger für Control verwendet, ja.
Ich lande auch öfters dazwischen.
Das nächste ist...
Das nächste ist, dass die Tasten keine schöne Oberfläche haben.
Die sind sehr rutschig.
Die sind einfach halt...
Die sind nicht nur glatt, die sind so poliert glatt.
Kann dir die hier empfehlen?
Erstmal Amazon RevLink.
GG.
Äh, ich gucke mir das trotzdem mal an.
Chakun RGB.
Weiß nicht.
Zu günstig.
Unter 200 Euro geht nix.
Nee, weißt du, ich muss...
Ich muss...
Ohne Scheiß.
Ich muss erstmal ein bisschen rumgucken.
So, das ist das nächste Problem, dass die Tasten mir zu, man könnte sagen, zu schlüpfrig sind im Endeffekt.
Meinung zu Forsenboys.
Ich gucke mir Forsen kaum an.
Aber die Sachen, die ich geguckt habe, fand ich nicht schlecht.
Ohne jetzt erklären zu können, warum, ist so ein bisschen wie...
Ich gucke auch manchmal Grip und ich weiß auch nicht, warum ich Grip gucke.
Wahrscheinlich, weil mein Salzgehalt im Blut nicht hoch genug ist oder so.
Keine Ahnung.
Aber wenn ich mir das angucke, dann finde ich es eigentlich ganz gut.
Und ich weiß, Forsenboys ist, glaube ich, das Reddit von ihm.
Na, das ist ja...
Aber das, das lese ich nicht.
Einziger Discord und, und, äh, auch, auch Meme-Reddit von irgendeinem Twitch-Streamer, wo ich drauf bin, ist XQC.
Und ich gucke XQC schon eine ganze Weile nicht mehr.
Einfach, ich fand den Chat schon immer anstrengend.
Aber ich fand den Chat cool anstrengend.
Aber jetzt mittlerweile mit 16.000 Zuschauern...
Du...
Da...
Es passiert auch nichts Lustiges mehr im Chat, sondern es wird einfach nur hirnlos gespammt.
Das ist doof.
So.
Ähm, also weiter im Text.
Was mich an der Tastatur stört.
Wie gesagt, da rutscht es öfter mit dem Finger rein.
Und die Tasten sind mir zu schlüpfrig im Endeffekt.
Dazu kommt, dass die Tasten für meinen Geschmack nicht fest genug sind.
Äh, Titan Toast gucke ich mir gleich auch nochmal an.
Das die...
Ah, das ist ja der Klassiker.
Die, die Cherry-Tastatur.
Oh ne, die kann...
Ach ne, ist das eine mit...
Das ist eine mit...
Mit flachen Tasten, oder?
Flache Tasten kann ich gar nicht.
Da kann ich...
Da komme ich nicht mit klar.
Oder sieht das auf dem Bild nur so aus?
Ähm, dazu kommt, dass die Tasten für meinen Geschmack ein bisschen viel Spielraum haben.
Ich meine, Tasten, egal bei welcher Tastatur, sind die Tasten ja im Endeffekt immer nur draufgesteckt.
Ist ja logisch.
Ich meine, du hast unten drunter was auch immer.
Rubber Dome oder irgendwelche mechanischen Geschichten.
Sei es jetzt die...
Diese Sache hier.
Oder sei es irgendwie...
Wie heißt das andere?
Buckle...
Ne, äh...
Spring...
Buckle...
Spring oder so.
Das alte IBM-Zeug ist im Prinzip egal.
Aber...
Klar, die Tasten sind alle nur aufgesteckt.
Aber, ich finde, hier haben sogar die Tastaturen...
Die wackeln!
Also sprich...
Ich versuche euch das mal zu zeigen.
Also sie wackeln für meinen Geschmack zu viel.
Dass sie ein bisschen wackeln ist okay.
Ich zeige euch mal was.
Ich habe jetzt die Hand auf W...
Auf...
Ich wollte gerade sagen, auf W-A-S-D.
Aber auf W-A-D.
Und wenn ich jetzt...
Hin und her wackele...
Mit meinem Finger.
Also quasi das...
Was man halt macht.
Wo man gerade rum eidelt.
Und wartet, dass was passiert.
Und man nicht straveln will.
Hört, hört mal hin.
Die wackeln mir ein bisschen viel.
Weiß nicht, ob man das jetzt gehört hat.
Das ist nicht wirklich viel mehr als bei anderen Tastaturen.
Aber es ist gefühlt mehr.
Und es ist...
Ach, man hört es nicht.
Wegen meinem Noisegate hört man das nicht.
Wartet mal.
Äh...
Hallo.
Klar, kann man gar nicht hören.
Äh...
Ich muss mein Noisegate ausmachen.
Filters.
Noisegate.
Okay.
Vielleicht hört man es jetzt.
Haben wir es jetzt gehört?
Naja, gut.
Was auch immer.
Ähm...
Das sind halt...
Ich habe jetzt einfach die Finger auf W-A-D gehabt.
Und habe die Finger hin und her gewackelt.
Nicht die Tasten.
Und die Tasten wackeln halt mit den Fingern so weit hin und her, dass man das halt so hört.
Ähm...
Noisegate.
Gefällt mir auch nicht.
Das sind alles so Punkte.
Die sind auch...
Recht...
Persönlich von mir.
Also das ist jetzt nichts, wo ich sagen würde...
Das ist jetzt für jeden K.O.-Kriterium.
Diese Tastatur.
Zu kaufen.
Ne, ne.
Die Tastatur an sich ist nicht schlecht.
Die hat wirklich viele Features.
Und an sich ist es eigentlich eine ziemlich gute Tastatur.
Aber nicht für mich.
Das war für mich halt ein totaler Fehlkauf.
So, was habe ich noch geschrieben?
Da ich jetzt nicht zweimal überlegen muss.
Ähm...
Genau.
Das ist auch...
Das habe ich ja schon gehabt.
Mit dem...
Äh...
Dass man manchmal...
Dass man nicht spürt, wo manche Knöpfe sind.
Ah ja.
Ähm...
Dazu kommt auch noch...
Dass...
Ähm...
Auf F und...
Äh...
J.
Ist ja...
So ein...
Nippel drauf.
Ne?
Ducky Shine 7 habe ich noch nicht anguckt.
Aber ich habe eine Ducky Skyline auf der Arbeit.
Und ich habe es geschafft...
Von der F-Taste...
Diesen Erkennungshuppel...
Der da oben drauf ist...
So weit...
Durch einfach nur Fingerbewegen oben drauf...
So weit abzunutzen...
Dass man ihn im Vergleich zum J kaum noch spürt.
Und das ist bei einer...
Bei einer...
180 Euro oder sowas Tastatur...
Nach ungefähr einem Jahr...
Oder wann...
Wann habe ich die gekauft?
Der eineinhalb Jahre?
Ja?
Irgendwie so?
Ähm...
Bisschen länger vielleicht?
Das kann...
Das kann aber eigentlich auch nicht sein.
Dass...
Dass das sich so schnell abnutzt.
Ja?
Das darf...
Darf auch nicht sein.
Ähm...
War ich nicht lassen?
Genau.
Ein Problem, was ich damit habe, ist...
Ich habe das Gefühl, das Ding...
Zieht...
Ähm...
Echt Dreck und Staub an.
Ich dachte am Anfang, die Tastatur ist ziemlich Dreck- und Staubresistent.
Weil sie halt nicht so viele Rillen hat.
Und die Tasten auch relativ offen in der Luft hängen.
Nicht so viele...
Wie...
Wie so...
Ich kenne auch die alten...
Die alten Rubber-Dome-Tastaturen, wo quasi überall die Krümel rein sind.
Hier ist es anders.
Du kannst theoretisch ohne Probleme...
Pfff...
Hier so einmal durchpusten.
Weil die...
Weil die Tasten relativ...
Relativ frei stehen.
Aber trotzdem...
Das Ding...
Vor allem unten an der Gummiauflage...
Sammelt sich halt...
Echt viel...
Staub.
Ich müsste das Ding theoretisch...
Jeden Tag, nachdem ich da irgendwie fertig mit bin, erstmal eine Runde abputzen.
Dass das schön sauber bleibt.
Das ist keine Gummiauflage, das ist Plastik.
Ja, kann auch sein.
Außerdem fühlt sich die Auflage komisch an.
Wenn ich da mit den Fingern drüber gehe, ist es irgendwie...
Naja.
So, und das ist halt...
Recht subjektiv, aber halt...
Für mich war das der totale Fehlkauf, die Tastatur.
Ach ja!
Und das hier geht mir auch auf den Sack.
Die Software, die dabei ist, ist Crap.
Ich versuche euch das mal zu zeigen.
Habe ich die überhaupt an?
IQ?
Ich hoffe, das ist die aktuellste Variante.
Und die läuft ja auch hier auf meinem Account ohne Admin-Rechte richtig.
So, ich mache jetzt mal einen Prozessexplorer an.
Und es passt mal auf.
Die Tastatur-Software...
Die zieht permanent...
Es ist besser geworden.
Aber ich frage mich, warum muss eine Tastatur-Software...
Permanent CPU-Leistung ziehen?
Und es ist besser geworden.
Das waren mal 4-5%.
Von 8700...
Und ich habe mir gedacht, warum?
Was macht die denn?
Ich tippe auf der Tastatur nichts.
Warum zieht die Software überhaupt CPU-Leistung?
Ohne, dass ich sie benutze.
Ohne, dass sie einfach nur an ist.
Warum?
Das muss doch echt nicht sein.
Die Logitech-Software kriegt das beispielsweise auch ganz ohne Probleme hin.
Überhaupt kein Ding.
XD-Monty.
Moin.
Das kann nicht sein.
Und je nach Version ist es mal stärker ausgeprägt, mal weniger stark ausgeprägt.
Und ich habe auch das Gefühl, es hängt ein bisschen davon ab, wie viele Makros und so man drin hat.
Ähm...
Das sollte aber überhaupt nichts ziehen.
Ja, Failure.
2% ist ja richtig krass.
Aber wie gesagt, die hat früher auch mal mehr gezogen.
Die haben das wohl die letzten Versionen optimiert.
Ähm...
RGB habe ich ja gerade aus.
Ne, habe ich nicht.
Ha, es hat einfach nur nicht geleuchtet.
Ähm...
Aber RGB kannst du ja auch komplett ohne die Software anmachen.
Das macht ja die Tastatur eingebaut.
Also...
Das sind alle so Punkte, wo ich mir denke, das muss eigentlich nicht sein.
... Das muss eigentlich nicht sein.
Das muss eigentlich nicht sein.
Und deswegen habe ich mich dazu entschlossen, ich will eine neue Tastatur.
Oh je, heute habe ich ja auf Twitter was gepostet, Leute.
Will jetzt aber gar nicht so viel dazu erzählen, sonst flippen mich auch wieder alle aus.
Ich habe auf Twitter heute gepostet, dass ich es blöde finde, dass so viele Leute Sachen verbieten wollen.
Es wurde nämlich heute auf Twitter wieder diskutiert, ob man nicht Feuerwerk verbieten soll.
So, dann habe ich geschrieben, Leute, ich mache schon seit Jahren kein Feuerwerk mehr, aber ich finde den Ansatz blöde.
Immer direkt alles verbieten zu wollen, ohne sich da Gedanken drüber zu machen.
Alter, haben sich die Leute wieder aufgeregt.
Meine Güte, ey.
Was da wieder gekommen ist, ey.
So nach dem Motto, ich bin...
Ich wäre ein Tierquäler.
Äh, äh...
Ich bin Nazi-AfD-Wähler.
Ich war alles.
Einfach nur, weil ich gesagt habe...
Ich finde es blöd, die Sachen immer direkt zu verbieten.
Das ist der Wahnsinn.
Die Leute sind mittlerweile so...
Die haben so eine dünne Haut mittlerweile, alle Leute, dass alle instant...
Oder viele, nicht alle, sind ja nicht alle.
Haben ja auch viele draufgeschrieben, so nach dem Motto, ja, sehen sie anders.
Also viele haben auch ganz normal drauf reagiert.
Ähm...
Aber...
Die sind so dünnhäutig mittlerweile, die Leute, ey.
Das ist der Wahnsinn.
Ich meine, wenn man noch...
Ich meine, es ist Twitter.
Das ist...
Es ist...
Es ist eine relativ anonyme...
Anonyme Plattform im Internet.
Das heißt, weder ich noch der können uns da irgende...
Es können uns nix, ja?
Also man muss da eigentlich überhaupt keine...
Überhaupt keine Bedenken haben irgendwie.
Das heißt, gerade da könnte man doch ein bisschen, ähm...
Sich die Sache einfach mal anhören, ja?
Wie gesagt, ähm...
Ich muss jetzt nochmal so zwei, drei Minuten mal drauf rumreiten.
Ich mache selbst kein Feuerwerk.
Ich finde, Feuerwerk an Silvester ist eigentlich eines der unsinnigsten Sachen überhaupt.
Ähm...
Ich wäre von einem Verbot überhaupt nicht betroffen.
Wahrscheinlich würde ich sogar rein die Stille und, ähm...
Dass meine Katz keine Panik bekommt an Silvester.
Wahrscheinlich würde ich es sogar gut finden.
Aber was ich nicht gut finde ist,
dass das Erste, was den Leuten einfällt mittlerweile, ist, dass die Leute nicht mehr so gut sind.
Mittlerweile immer ist man so, soll die Sachen verbieten.
Ich habe auch gar nichts prinzipiell dagegen, ähm...
Wenn man, wenn man Sachen verbietet, aber nur, wenn man sich vorher Gedanken gemacht hat,
was es denn für Möglichkeiten gibt, sagen wir mal, die Probleme, die man eben erkannt hat, äh, zu ändern.
So, und wenn man sich Gedanken dazu gemacht hat, und danach sagt zu irgendeinem Problem,
hey, uns fällt nichts Gescheites ein, oder alle, alle Lösungsansätze sind doof,
wir verbieten das,
ey, dann lasse ich mir es dir irgendwie gefallen.
Aber bei allem, was irgendwie einem nicht passt, gleich schreien zu verbieten,
was will man als nächstes verbieten? Nudel essen.
Nudel essen, das ist, ich fühle mich auch unglaublich angegriffen dadurch, dass manche Leute Nudel essen.
Ja, das wird, das wird dann immer mehr.
Und das ist das, wo ich meine, wo ich meine Bedenken habe, ne?
Mir geht es gar nicht so sehr um irgendwie, irgendwie Feuerwerk oder sonst irgendwas, ähm,
sondern, dass man als erstes immer auf die Idee kommt,
Sachen,
verbieten zu wollen.
Weil eins ist klar, meiner Ansicht nach, ähm,
wenn man,
wenn das erste, was einem einfällt, ist,
Sachen
zu verbieten,
dann besteht überhaupt kein Bedarf mehr,
sich um was Gedanken zu machen.
Das heißt nämlich,
ähm, automatisch, dadurch, dass man es mit einfach, wir verbieten, gut ist, Haken drunter,
heißt es, man muss sich zu Problemen, die es gibt, keine Gedanken machen.
Das ist eigentlich schlecht, weil keine Gedanken machen heißt auch automatisch,
dass es keine neuen Denkanstöße, keine neuen, äh, äh,
Richtungen oder sowas in der Richtung gibt.
Das heißt, wenn man zu allem, was irgendwie Probleme macht,
entweder ignoriert, verbietet, oder, oder wegdefiniert,
kommt da am Ende nichts Gescheites bei raus.
Ja, äh, das ist eigentlich das, ja, aber, Alter, wie da die Leute abgegangen sind.
Und wisst ihr, was das Highlight, wisst ihr, was mein absoluter Highlight-Tweet war,
wo einer geschrieben hat, äh,
also, nicht nur einer, es haben mehrere Leute geschrieben.
Also, ihr, ihr müsst mir jetzt, äh, ich kann die Argumentation nicht ganz nachvollziehen.
Hast du dir mal Coolmaster Masterkeys angucken?
Nee, schreib mir das aber mal auf, ich guck mir das gleich an.
Also, mein Lieblingsargument, also, Argument, wenn man das so nennen kann, überhaupt, ja,
was einer gebracht hat, war, ähm, ähm, so sinngemäß, ähm,
dann müsste man ja auch Mord erlauben,
weil es schränkt ja sonst die Freiheit ein.
Da hab ich mir auch gedacht, sag mal,
vergleichen die Leute wirklich ernsthaft gerade Feuerwerk zünden mit Leuten, die andere Leute umbringen?
Da hab ich mir gedacht, okay, also, ich, die Leute sind echt, haha, teilweise,
ich weiß, da weißt du, bei so ner, bei so nem, bei so ner Antwort weißt du gar nicht, wo du anfangen sollst, eigentlich.
Da weißt du gar nicht, wo du anfangen sollst, was dagegen zu sagen, weil es so absurd ist.
Total, total, wie?
Also, allein schon, allein schon der Gedankensprung ist irgendwie merkwürdig
und was ich den Leuten immer dann gerne sagen würde, ist, so, willkommen in der Realität.
Die Welt ist halt nicht schwarz oder weiß, das heißt nur, weil du eine Sache erlaubst oder verbietest,
heißt das nicht automatisch, dass du alles andere auch erlauben oder verbieten müsstest.
Das ist eigentlich relativ logisch.
Naja, gut.
Ah ja, da könnt ihr mir jetzt echt wieder drüber auslassen.
Aber, ich, ich kann's nicht verstehen.
Und einer hat dann auch geschrieben, so nach dem Motto, Max, ich entfolge dir jetzt, obwohl ich dir jahrelang folge,
ähm, weil ich ihm, ja, ich geb's so ein bissl blöde Antwort geschrieben hab, aber,
oh Mann, oh Mann, Leute, ich versteh's nicht.
Du bist Informatiker, was verstehst du von Logik?
Ja, offensichtlich...
Nix.
Ich kann Binary-Logik, aber ich kann definitiv nicht Twitter-Logik.
Aber ich glaube, Twitter-Logik kann keiner.
Ah ja, und was auch toll war,
Alter,
mal gucken, ob ich das jetzt finde,
ähm,
Alter, guckt euch das mal an, das haben voll viele geliked,
oder fand's schlecht,
ähm, ja, da, da, was auch toll war, so, so, so, so, so, so nach dem Motto,
die Leute nach dem Motto, oh Gott, wenn, wenn Leuten, denen ich lange folge, wenn die dann quasi immer konservativer oder sonst was sind,
also, solange kann der mir eigentlich noch gar nicht folgen.
Ich würd mich weder als jetzt irgendwie, ich würd mich eigentlich als nix, keine, keine wirklich spezielle Richtung einordnen.
Ich, ich würd eher sagen, ich bin zukunftsorientiert.
Ich mach mir Gedanken drüber, wie man, wie man Sachen machen könnte,
weil jetzt haben wir die Möglichkeit, Sachen zu beeinflussen,
weil, guckt euch die Umweltgeschichte an,
wenn's erst mal kurz vor knapp ist, ist es immer scheiße, was zu machen,
ähm, es kann doch für alle nur von Vorteil sein,
und das ist das, was ich aktuell auch nicht so ganz, ganz verstehe,
es kann doch eigentlich unterm Strich für alle nur von Vorteil sein,
wenn man rechtzeitig über Probleme miteinander redet.
Das Problem ist aber, es funktioniert nicht.
Wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel, nur mal, nur mal ein Beispiel, ja,
ähm, also wenn ich jetzt sagen würde, ähm, es ist jetzt nur ein Beispiel, ja,
so, mal angenommen, wenn ich jetzt sagen würde, hier, ähm,
Inder und Chinesen haben sich die letzten Jahrzehnte hauptsächlich, äh, vegetarisch ernährt.
Das kann man nachgucken, ja, das ist so, guckt euch aber auch mal die asiatische Küche an.
So, allerdings, die letzten Jahre, da gibt es auch Statistiken zu, ähm,
die letzten Jahre ist der Fleischkonsum, vor allem in Indien und China, steigt, so.
Das ist so, das kann man sich nachgucken.
Und da stelle ich mir natürlich die Frage, wenn, vor allem jetzt im indischen und asiatischen,
vor allem im chinesischen Raum, die Leute mehr Fleisch futtern wollen,
wo sollen wir die ganzen Tiere anbauen?
Das Problem ist, dieses Thema kannst du gar nicht ansprechen, weil,
als erstes ist jemand getriggert, der sagt, Max, du hast Inder gesagt, scheiß AfD-Wähler,
scheiß Nazi.
Als nächstes ist da Veganer getriggert, der sagt, was, Fleisch, Tiere, oh, ja, piss dich, Alter.
Dabei will ich weder das eine noch das andere sagen.
Ich würde mir einfach nur gerne Gedanken drüber machen, wie, wie, wie, was könnte man da so machen, ja?
Und ich meine, die werden bestimmt nicht sagen, oder wir auch nicht,
es wird, es wird keine der beiden Seiten sagen, so nach dem Motto, ja,
wir verzichten auf irgendwas.
Das passiert in der Regel nie.
Deswegen muss man sich Gedanken drüber machen.
Zum Beispiel könnte man sagen, was, was ein, ein Lösungsansatz mehr,
wir könnten sagen, okay, wir haben das Problem, was sich anbahnt, relativ früh erkannt.
Das ist erstmal schon mal gut, wenn man, wenn man Probleme früh erkennt.
Wir haben das Problem relativ früh erkannt.
Jetzt beteiligen wir uns zum Beispiel an der Forschung,
wie man aus Zellen im Labor Fleisch herstellen könnte.
Das wäre ein Lösungsansatz.
Dass man sagt, okay, man braucht jetzt, um Fleisch herzustellen,
muss man keine Tiere mehr umbringen.
Man braucht gar keine Tiere mehr.
Das finden die Leute aber dann komischerweise auch kacke.
Allen voran irgendwelche Biobauern finden das kacke,
weil, ja, man kann ja auch verstehen, die leben davon irgendwie.
Warum kann man nicht sagen, okay, wir haben das Problem erkannt,
wir bauen uns quasi ein gewisses Know-how in diesem Bereich auf,
der definitiv wichtig werden wird in Zukunft.
Ob es auf diese Art und Weise passieren wird, keine Ahnung.
Aber das Problem wird über kurz oder lang passieren.
Wenn wir jetzt quasi frühzeitig anfangen würden,
ein gewisses Know-how in dem Bereich aufzubauen,
weil Inder und Chinesen machen das garantiert.
Und vor allem die Chinesen haben ethisch da weniger Probleme als wir
mit irgendwelchen Zellforschungen oder sonst was.
Ja.
Das juckt die relativ wenig.
Vielleicht ist es bis dahin anders, keine Ahnung.
Das heißt, wir könnten uns sogar theoretisch in dem Bereich
ein gewisses Know-how, Wissensvorsprung erarbeiten,
der allen hier eigentlich über lange Zeit nutzen würde.
Weil ich meine, wenn man sich in einem Bereich auskennt,
der dann wirklich wichtig wird und man Leute hat, Know-how hat,
Technologie hat, Firmen haben, die das Ganze können,
das bringt uns natürlich auch was.
Ich meine, wir exportieren jetzt schon viel,
warum soll man nicht auch sowas machen?
Keine Ahnung.
Aber über sowas kannst du ja nicht reden,
weil sobald du Inder sagst, kommt der Erste an,
scheiß AfD-Wähler-Nazi, obwohl er überhaupt nicht gehört hat,
um was es geht.
Und wenn du sagst Fleisch, kommt der Vegane an
und ist getriggert, weil du das Wort Fleisch in den Mund genommen hast.
Und dann kommt der Nächste an und sagt, direkt alles verbieten.
Und das ist eigentlich das, was ich mit meinem Tweet sagen wollte,
dass mir das auf den Sack geht.
Aber die Leute lesen im Endeffekt nur das, was sie lesen wollen,
aus solchen Tweets raus.
Kam auch schon der Erste an, der gesagt hat,
ich habe ja auf einen geantwortet, so nach dem Motto,
ja, man liest immer nur das, was man rauslesen will.
Dann kam der Erste an und hat gemeint,
Max, das ist eine AfD-Trump-Aussage.
Ah ja, alles klar.
Oh Mann.
Twitter, Alter, Twitter.
Mechanisch oder Rubberdome?
Mechanisch.
Rubberdome nur,
wenn es unbedingt leise sein muss.
So, ich habe jetzt den Chat ein bisschen,
nach meinem Monolog hier,
ein bisschen den Chat vernachlässigt.
Ja, Patrick, genau, das sagen ja auch manche.
Ist doch wieder Witz, ne?
Ähm.
Habe gestern mit meinem Dead RGB in das Home Cinema entschieden.
Oh, huge.
Kann man hier nicht donaten?
Doch, ich hatte mal einen Donation-Link,
aber die, bei Steam Labs,
die Einplanung für Donation waren kaputt,
da habe ich es weggemacht.
Das heißt, kannst du Prime-Sub da lassen,
was übrigens jeder machen kann,
es kostet überhaupt nichts,
bringt euch alle Vorteile und dem Streamer alle Vorteile.
Heißt nicht, dass ihr unbedingt mich subscriben müsst.
Aber natürlich freue ich mich über jeden Sub.
Ähm.
Du kannst mich aber auch natürlich normal abonnieren.
Und das ist auch nicht verpflichtend,
dass es irgendwie automatisch verlängert wird oder so.
Keine Abo-Falle.
Kann einfach da sein.
Ich freue mich auch über alle Leute, die zugucken, die im Chat sind,
wenn der Chat aktiv ist.
Und der, der Nebulon sagt, muss sagen,
dass ihm der ganze Kreta-Hype auf den Sack geht.
Oh, wenn ich mit dem Thema jetzt anfange,
dann höre ich nochmal auf.
Ja, Mark G. Blaze,
das ist eh schwierig, wie man Sachen mittlerweile nennen darf.
Da muss ich mal überlegen,
wie beknackt das eigentlich ist,
dass man überhaupt nicht mehr um Inhalt,
oder sehr wenig,
sagen wir mal, sehr wenig um Inhalt diskutiert,
sondern, dass irgendjemand
die nicht korrekten Wörter verwendet.
Wenn du Ausländer sagst,
ist schon mal schlimm.
Ich meine, ganz ehrlich,
ich habe meinen Zivildienst gemacht
in einer Behindertenwerkstatt.
Das hieß so. Heute hast du schon das Problem,
wenn du Behinderter sagst.
Heute heißt das besonders.
Das ist jetzt kein Scherz.
So, gleich bin ich mit dem Chat durch.
Ja, Tribulon, hast du recht.
Digitale Entwicklung von Deutschland
ist unter anderem genau deswegen
auch im Arsch.
Oh, das ist wieder Secret of Mana, oder?
30?
Ne, ist es nicht.
Okay, okay, okay.
Besser.
Was für Browser Addons benutzt du?
Also hier habe ich aktuell nur
drauf U-Block Origin,
Dark Reader,
wobei Dark Reader umstritten ist, muss man sagen.
Dark Reader hat ja Zugriff auf die Seiten,
muss das Addon haben,
weil sonst könnte es die Seiten nicht
dunkel machen.
Das ist umstritten, aber es ist noch
ein Source-Projekt, also meine
Bedenken halten sich in Grenzen.
FFZ für Twitch Emotes,
und ich glaube, das war's,
was ich hier habe.
Ah, Live Server Extension, das ist, wenn ich was
programmiere, dass der Browser automatisch reloadet.
Und Audio Pick, das habe ich mal
vor einer Weile verwendet, da konnte man einstellen,
welches Tab welche Soundkarte verwendet.
Bei mir auf dem anderen Rechner verwende ich auch nicht
so wirklich viel mehr.
Mal überlegen, ich glaube gar nichts
Großartiges mehr.
Ich habe noch ein Addon, das meine Bookmarks
in die Nextcloud synct.
Richtig gut, kann ich allen empfehlen,
die sowas suchen, hier, Flokus.
Da kannst du, hast du
einen Addon, gibst deine Nextcloud Daten
ein, und dann synct der
deine Browser Bookmarks
in die Nextcloud, und nicht etwa
mit einem eigenen Fenster, sondern die
Native Bookmarks aus dem
... was ist denn
MonkaSpeed?
Sondern die Native Bookmarks aus dem
Browser. Ah!
Das ist
sehr praktisch, das kann man nur empfehlen.
Nach was suchst du genau
für eine Tastatur? Ich suche nach einer Tastatur,
die sich gut eignet zum Spielen und zum
Programmieren, also im Prinzip zum Tippen
und zum Spielen. Deswegen kommt für mich
keiner dieser IBM Tastatur nachbauen
und mit ordentlicher Makro Software.
Deswegen kommt für mich keine
...
IBM Nachbau Tastatur in Frage, weil
die haben diese, wie heißt das?
Spring IBM
Keyboard
Buckling Spring,
genau.
Die haben eine ziemlich schlechte
Latency, was das angeht.
Die brauchen eine ganze Weile, bis sie reagiert
haben, dass die Taste gedrückt wurde. Das ist
nicht weiter wild, wenn man schreibt, das fühlt sich
wahrscheinlich sogar gut an, aber wenn man hier den
Overwatch-AD-AD-AD-Spam macht,
dann ist das schlecht.
Was willst du für eine Art von Tastatur?
Format, Linear, Taktilität?
Also ich will auf jeden Fall
was mit NumBlock.
Was hast du gegen RubberDome?
Nix.
Prinzipiell nix.
Außer, dass es sich,
ich hab mich jetzt ja sowohl auf der Arbeit als auch hier
an was mechanisches gewöhnt,
dass mir der Druck der Tasten nicht mehr gefällt.
Und außerdem
...
Vielleicht ist auch nur viel
Gefühl dabei, also ich hab jetzt da keine Benchmarks
gemacht oder so, ist die Reaktionszeit
in Spielen auch
deutlich angenehmer.
Und differenzierter zwischen den Tastendrücken.
Also wenn du auf einer RubberDome ADAD,
wenn du diesen ADAD-Spam machst,
auf einer RubberDome, dann kriegst du das so schnell
gar nicht hin und es fühlt sich wabbelig an.
Also ich will auf jeden Fall
NumBlock.
Welche Switche? Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Auf der Arbeit hab ich ne
Ducky One Skyline mit, was ist das?
Brown-Switches?
Schau mal bei Hardverdienst, der hat gute Empfehlungen.
Ja, der empfiehlt die K95 Platinum,
die ich austauschen will.
Wo bist du denn, Patrick?
Deine Grafikkarte ist kaputt.
Ähm.
Auf der Seite war ich vorher auch schon.
Candy Keys.
Ähm.
Ja, die wurde mir
auch empfohlen, die hier.
Morpheus. Genau die hier wurde mir empfohlen.
Und zwar.
Schau mal welche. Die hab ich auch ernsthaft
überlegt. Und zwar.
Oh, ich hab glaub ich.
Irgendeine Abwandlung davon
wurde mir empfohlen.
Wobei die ist halt genau mit dieser
Buckling Spring
Technik, wo halt
Input Delay relativ
hoch ist.
Also ich hätte so eine ganz stink, gerne stinknormale
äh, neumodig
mechanische und nicht die, kein IBM
Nachbau.
Was empfehlt ihr für eine Cloud?
Kommt drauf an. Für was?
Für was brauchst du es denn? G-Stealth.
Die Rocket
Amo 120. Nee.
Aber alles, was ich bisher von Rocket hatte, hat
mich qualitativ nicht überzeugt.
Mit Razer sieht es ähnlich aus.
Okay, Hauptsache RGB.
Das sind runde Tasten.
Und naaah.
Mag ich nicht.
Ich mag keine gewölbten Tasten.
Das ist schon mal nix für mich.
Gewölbte Tasten mag ich nicht.
Schon mal das Keyboard angeschaut.
Ja, hatte ich mir angeschaut für die Arbeit,
bevor ich mir ne Duckie One Skyline bestellt hab.
Ich kann dir nicht mal sagen, was genau
mir daran nicht gepasst hat.
Aber irgendwas hat mir daran nicht gepasst.
Aber ich guck's mir nochmal an.
Ja, also so sieht's aus.
Wollte mich nur mal bedanken, dass du mich früher, als ich
12-16 war, auf den Geschmack
von der Ausbildung zum Fachinformatiker
gebracht hast.
Big Brain Ausbildung.
Und ich jetzt in einem Berufszweig arbeite,
der mir extrem viel Spaß macht.
Und Geldtechnik geht's mir aktuell sehr, sehr gut.
Das ist schön.
Wisst du mal, Youtube Videos lohnt sich,
wenn man die richtigen Leute guckt.
Viel Glück und Youtube und der L.
Ja, dankeschön.
Nice, Monty.
Das war's für heute.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Tschüss.
Der einzige Grund, warum ich mir keine Ducky
in One Skyline bestelle,
für daheim ist, weil ich
gerne eine ordentliche Makro-Software
haben will.
Und die Makro-Funktion mit der
Ducky ist ein bisschen merkwürdig.
Die hat auf der Rückseite so ein Jumper-Ding, wo man Makros
macht. Also ich will schon eine komplette
Makro-Lösung haben, die auch erkennen kann,
in welchem Fenster ich bin und sowas. Also das muss
was mit Zusatzsoftware sein, zum Installieren.
Jitz, Martin. Fünf Monate.
Huge. Nice.
Dankeschön.
Sa-sa-sa-sa-sa-sa-sa-muscle
Nice.
Kutztap! Fünf Monate in Folge.
Am 4.1. kann ich zwar schon wieder hereins-
Ja. Das ist ja
huge.
Das hier ist das Home Cinema. Das gucken wir uns jetzt an.
Hm. Kennen wir nicht so viel drauf.
Zeig mal. Was hast'n da am Start?
Ähm.
Mark G. Blaze. Zeig mal her.
Das Home Cinema.
Warum macht man Fotos im Hochformat?
Anne will.
Na gut.
Jeder soll jeder gucken, was er will.
Man erkennt leider nicht allzu viel.
Man erkennt hier eine Couch.
Man erkennt, dass du...
Was ist das da oben?
Sound?
Das ist wahrscheinlich auch Sound, hä?
Ist das überhaupt...
Ist das ein Fernseher oder ist das ein...
Diemer.
Ist schon ein Fernseher, oder?
Ja, das ist ein Fernseher.
Ja, da ist eine Sache.
Man erkennt leider nicht so viel drauf.
Aber ist bestimmt ein nices Home Cinema.
Wieso sollte ich meine Bookmarks in die Cloud ballern,
an das du sie zwischen verschiedenen Browsern benutzen kannst?
Übrigens geht es nicht um die Cloud,
sondern um Nextcloud.
Also quasi das, was bei dir gehostet ist.
Irgendjemand hat auch vorhin gefragt,
welche Cloud man verwenden soll.
Da habe ich gesagt, für was hat derjenige schon geantwortet.
Irgendwas mit Stealth?
Okay, Anon.
Na, wenn die schnell sind.
Was für eine Mechane-Tastatur ist da auf der Arbeit?
Wie gesagt, eine Ducky-One-Skyline.
Ich bin ein bisschen hinterher mit dem Chat.
Warte mal, ich muss erstmal wieder runter scrollen.
Igitt.
Five Happy, was ist denn das?
Das sieht ja eklig aus.
Kann man das nicht groß machen?
Das sieht ja...
Was soll denn das sein?
Willst du mich debaten, oder was?
Das ist irgendeine Tastatur
für den...
für irgendwie einen Geldautomat oder so.
Was soll das sein?
Äh, Anon, dann schick mal einen Link
zu einem Rubber-Dome, der gut ist.
Ich habe schon...
Ich habe da selten was empfohlen gesehen.
Äh, Max, welchen Netzwerkschrank
hast du noch mal im Einsatz?
Gar keinen.
Ich habe ein offenes 19-Zoll-Rack.
Kein Netzwerkschrank.
Also, Chuck690,
ich komme mit der K95.
Ich habe es ja am Anfang erzählt.
K95-Platinium, überhaupt nicht klar.
Max, hast du die neue A15?
Kannst du die empfehlen?
Nee.
Astro-Headsets
brauche ich mir nicht.
Ah, hier.
Handy, Backup, täglich und Bilder.
Also, ähm,
das ist eine Frage,
die haben wahrscheinlich relativ viele,
weil, wenn jemand fragt,
so nach dem Motto,
was ist die beste Cloud?
Es könnte ja auch sein,
dass du Sachen in der Cloud hosten willst.
Da würde ich mal ganz uneigennützig,
also ganz unbestochen von Microsoft,
ähm,
würde ich sagen Azure.
Ähm, nee,
aber für eine normale Cloud,
du willst eigentlich,
keine Cloud,
du willst,
du willst Backups machen.
Also,
sprich,
wenn es dir nicht darum geht,
dass das irgendwie,
äh,
super synced
und multistand und sowas,
du willst eigentlich
dein Handy-Backup hochladen,
nimm einfach irgendwas
0850-mäßiges,
je nachdem,
wie viel Speicherplatz du brauchst.
Wenn du einfach nur
Handy-Backup machen willst,
nimm, keine Ahnung,
nimm Google Drive,
ja.
Ich meine,
da kriegst du wie viel Gigabyte
mittlerweile standardmäßig?
Zehn?
Weiß gar nicht,
aber genug.
Und für Google Drive
gibt es alle möglichen Clients.
Äh,
wenn du ein bisschen mehr
speichern willst,
gibt es noch andere Varianten.
Was auch,
was auch eine Option ist,
ähm,
falls du das machen willst,
du kannst natürlich auch
bei dir daheim
eine Festplatte hinstellen
mit,
sagen wir mal,
mit einem,
ich sag mal,
einem Computer dran,
das kann auch ein Raspberry sein,
das ist egal,
ähm,
wo du dann jeden Tag syncst,
wenn du bei dir im WLAN bist.
Das ist auch eine Option,
wenn du sowas machen willst.
Du darfst nämlich
immer nicht vergessen,
die Clouds sind auch nur Computer,
die woanders stehen.
Nutzst du irgendeinen
Bookmark-Manager,
um bei all den Links und Tabs
nichts zu vergessen?
Ich fäll bei dem Game,
ja,
hab ich doch grad vorhin gezeigt,
hier,
den da verwende ich.
Ähm,
Flokus,
das ist,
das ist kein Bookmark-Manager,
das ist ein Sync
für Bookmarks.
Ein Sync für Bookmarks
in,
in Nextcloud rein.
So,
das heißt,
man kann das Ganze
im Chrome verwenden,
im Firefox verwenden
und es verwendet
die Native Bookmarks
aus dem,
aus dem jeweiligen Browser
und dann,
dann braucht man halt
eine halbwegs ordentliche
Ordnerstruktur.
Ich hab,
jetzt hier hab ich
nicht so viel,
normalerweise hab ich
sowas wie,
äh,
Programmieren,
dann für die Arbeit
und halt irgendwelche
aktuellen Sachen,
irgendwie Musik-Video-Kram,
ich hab nicht so viel.
Also ich bin eh nicht,
das habt ihr ja wahrscheinlich
mittlerweile mitgekriegt,
ich bin eh nicht der große,
äh,
Organisator,
was, äh,
Sachen angeht mit Tags
und Kategorien und sowas.
Deswegen ist für mich
immer wichtig,
dass, ähm,
wenn ich was verwende,
so wie ein Notizprogramm
oder ein Bookmarker,
oder, oder,
To-Dos oder sowas,
dass es immer
eine gute Suchfunktion hat.
Ich kann mir viel einfacher
Textschnipsel im Kopf merken,
nach denen ich suchen muss,
als, ähm,
die Sachen kategorisieren.
Vielleicht geht's ja noch
irgendwem so.
Ich weiß immer,
was ich ungefähr geschrieben habe,
bloß nicht mehr wo.
Das heißt,
für mich ist die Suchfunktion
das Wichtigste
und der Rest brauchen wir
eigentlich nicht.
Mechanische Tastaturen
sind zu laut,
sagt peinliche Affe.
Äh,
ich hab mir für die Arbeit,
weil ich hab, wie gesagt,
Lucky One Skyline
auf,
ich hab mir
so, so, so, so, so, so,
Plastikringe
gekauft.
Findet man das,
wenn man das hier sucht?
Nee.
Äh,
Ringe.
Hm.
Ich hab mir so
Gummiringe gekauft
und hab's mir,
wenn ich jetzt Gummi suche,
find ich bestimmt
irgendwelche Kondome
oder so.
Ja.
Keyboard Gummi.
Hehe.
Sowas,
sowas hier
hab ich mir da gekauft
in der Richtung.
Ähm,
mein,
war,
huge picture,
muss man ja mal sagen.
Man hätte das,
man hätte das kontrastmäßig
nicht besser aufnehmen können,
dieses Bild.
Ähm,
da sind so kleine
Plastikringe
oder Silikonringe.
Die kann man unter die Tasten machen,
wo man besonders hart draufhaut.
Was bei mir
hauptsächlich
die Leertaste ist
und
der Enter-Knopf
auf dem Numblock.
Da hab ich das drunter gemacht,
dass die Leute auf der Arbeit
nicht gar so sehr nerven
mit, mit, äh,
Einschlagen
auf meine Tastatur.
Lucky One Skyline
und Vortex.
Von Vortex
hab ich noch gar nix gehört.
Vortex Keyboard.
Zahl ich schon mal her.
Muss ich mir mal angucken.
Programmable Hotkeys.
Jaja.
Naja,
also sag mal so,
ich,
ich brauch eigentlich
gar keine extra Hotkeys
an der Tastatur.
Eigentlich stören die mich
fast nur.
Ich brauch aber
eine ordentlich programmierbare
Makro-Software.
Ja,
zum Beispiel,
was ich machen möchte
mit meiner Makro-Software,
ich möchte,
dass die erkennt,
welches,
welche Anwendung
gerade Fokus hat,
dass ich andere Sachen
einstellen kann,
ich bin verwirrt,
äh,
dass ich andere einstellen,
andere Sachen einstellen kann,
wenn ich in der Linux-VM bin,
als wie wenn ich zum Beispiel
in Windows bin.
Übrigens,
hab ich euch erzählt,
dass ich heute mein neues
Fire HD 8
gef, äh,
nicht geflasht,
sondern de-amazonifiziert
hab und es total einfach
gewesen ist.
Was?
Was,
was für ein Ding?
Wooting to Lecker-Idee.
Edition.
Das Ding heißt wirklich so?
So lange es nicht
Licker-Edition ist.
Wooting 2 Lecker-Edition.
Was,
Namen für Tastaturen,
ey.
Ja,
die,
äh,
Namen,
das ist bestimmt,
das ist bestimmt irgendwas,
was Schwedisches oder so
vom Namen her.
Extra-Gerät für Makros.
Denn Extra-Gerät für Makros
bringt mir nicht wirklich was,
es sei denn,
also ich weiß,
dass es so,
so programmierbare
Zwischenstecker gibt,
ähm,
aber wie gesagt,
ich will ja eine Makro-Software,
die auch erkennt,
welches Fenster Fokus hat
und sowas.
Äh,
Corsair hat keine
allzu nice Makro-Software.
Corsair hat dieses Ding hier,
was eigentlich
außer langsam sein
und,
äh,
nerven nicht allzu viel kann.
Ich hatte auch keine Schmerzen mit,
ein externes,
sag mal so,
externes
Hardware-Tool
zu verwenden
für Makros,
dann aber halt mit ordentlicher
Makro-Software halt auch
mit Betriebssystem-Integration.
Wofür brauchst du das NumPad eigentlich?
Ähm,
das NumPad,
brauch ich einmal zum
Zahlentippen,
ich weiß,
Big,
Big Brain,
ja.
Ähm,
aber ich brauch das NumPad,
ehrlich gesagt,
äh,
hauptsächlich,
um Enter zu hauen.
Das ist meine häufigst genutzte,
eine meiner häufigst genutzten Tasten
auf der Tastatur.
NumBlock Enter.
Aber ich tipp gerne
längere Nummern auf dem NumPad.
Jetzt war Geißhals ein Filter
für Makros,
gute Frage.
Max ist 5 Kilometer
oben im Channel.
Jaja,
ich komm grad nicht hinterher.
Da sind zwei Links,
okay,
zeig ich mal her.
Nitz Keyboards.
Nice.
Okay,
jetzt hab ich genug Sachen
zum Nachgucken.
Ne,
ich hab noch kein Pornagotchi,
aber ich,
äh,
hab mir das ernsthaft überlegt.
Alter,
der Chat ist jetzt immer
grad bei Cloud-Sachen,
ich bin echt zu weit
hinten dran.
Was hältst du von
Mega.co.nz
kann man verwenden?
Und das Stück
Flokus kann,
ähm,
ne,
Flokus,
glaub ich,
unterstützt so ziemlich
gar nix,
außer den Sync
von, äh,
Bookmarks aus Chrome
und Firefox.
Also nix zusätzliches.
Warum schreibst du immer
eine ein,
sonst löst diese dann?
Ah,
siehste,
die Leute haben schon
hier gepostet.
Nein,
mit Auto-Hotkey
kann man vieles nicht machen.
Außerdem wird Auto-Hotkey
von vielen Spielen
als Cheat eingestuft.
Also,
ein Beispiel,
was du mit Auto-Hotkey
nicht machen kannst,
ist,
sende mal Eingaben
an eine VM,
geht nicht.
Weil Auto-Hotkey
auf Windows drauf ist
und, äh,
vor allem bei irgendeinem
Low-Level-USB-Tastatur-Buck
oder so.
Gibt es eigentlich
auch Open-Source-Makro-Software,
die man selber
auf die Tastaturflasche
nennen kann?
Ja,
gibt es.
Ich muss nur
die Tastatur unterstützen.
Logitech hat gute Software.
Das stimmt.
Logitech hat meiner Meinung nach
die beste,
die beste Makro-
beziehungsweise
Verwaltungssoftware.
Leider gefallen mir
die Logitech-Tastatur nicht.
Theoretisch würde das
auch mit dem
Elgato Stream Deck
gehen.
Hä?
Soll ich mit dem
Elgato Stream Deck
meine Tastatur-Makros machen?
Ähm,
wo habe ich es jetzt
hier besetzt?
Willst du eine QMK
oder,
nee,
warte mal,
wo war denn jetzt die Frage?
Muss nicht sein.
Äh,
was ist denn hier?
eine TMK oder MK,
äh,
QMK-fähige Tastatur.
Ich glaube,
das ist diese
Custom-Firmware-Geschichte,
ne?
Muss nicht unbedingt sein.
Muss nicht sein.
Ich will einfach
eine ordentliche,
eine ordentliche
Makro-Software dabei haben.
Nee,
die G710
gefällt mir nicht.
Was hast du genau
mit dem Amazon Fire HD
gemacht?
Ich habe, äh,
die XDA
Fire Toolbox
genommen.
Die da.
Das ist ein
Windows-Programm.
Und habe komplett
alles von Amazon
runtergeschmissen,
Google Play Store
installiert
und, ähm,
den Nova Launcher
drauf gemacht.
Und schon ist kaum
was von Amazon übrig.
Aber ich will,
ich will das jetzt
nicht zu breit treten
auf, äh,
dem Stream,
weil wir dürfen
nicht vergessen,
im Endeffekt ist das
hier immer noch
eine, äh,
alles quasi, äh,
Amazon,
wo wir uns gerade
hier befinden.
Äh, Logitech ist
hauptsächlich Lua-Zeug,
ja, also die, die,
die Details, ja.
Das ist das Video
mit den Makros.
Make any key
a macro.
Das gucken wir uns
jetzt mal an.
Das, das Gerät
habe ich vorher schon mal,
das müssen wir uns
jetzt mal angucken.
Das Gerät habe ich
vorher schon mal gesehen.
Das ist so ein Teil,
was so zwischen die,
also dieses, dieses,
das Ding hier,
was er da zeigt.
Da, das da.
Das stöpselt man
zwischen die Teile.
Die Tastatur.
Und kann dann quasi
eigene Makros mitprogrammieren.
Aber ich glaube nicht,
dass das, das ist,
was ich, und was ich, äh,
wirklich brauche.
Weil, wie gesagt,
ich will ja auch erkennen können,
ich brauche Betriebssystem-
Integration, also sprich,
meine Makro-Software
soll erkennen können,
welches Fenster
gerade fokussiert ist.
So, ich bin mit dem Chat
gleich, gleich
habe ich es geschafft.
Schreibt man schnell
in C, in C++
über Win32,
AP, nee, macht man nicht.
CB5, Twitch Prime,
Dankeschön.
Huge.
Nice.
First time sub.
Äh, Max baut
seine eigene Hotkey-Software
im nächsten Stream.
Nee, das ist leider
nicht so einfach.
Zumal das große Problem
bei Custom-Software ist,
und auch bei irgendwelchen
Low-Level-Keyboard-Hooks
und sonstigen Geschichten,
dass Spiele das mal
ganz gerne als Cheat einstufen.
Hast du dir mal
das Happy Hacking-Keyboard
angeschaut?
Nö.
Ich habe jetzt
jede Menge Tastaturen,
die ich mir angucken muss.
DRD Khan,
Twitch Prime,
Dankeschön.
POC.
Big Prime,
Big Brain Sub.
Hehehe.
Man schreibt alles,
alles, alles in Assembler,
alles andere ist nicht nach,
Hardware nach.
Gut.
Was ist Assembler?
Hex.
Alles in Hex,
direkt selbst.
Opcodes raussuchen
von Intel
und alles im Hex-Editor machen.
Wer benutzt denn
bitteschön so bloated Sachen
wie Assembler?
Also, ich bitte dich.
Okay, ich bin mit dem Chat
unten dran,
ich habe es geschafft.
Ich habe den Chat aufgeholt.
Assembler für Noobs,
richtig.
Okay, gucken wir uns mal
die Makro-Geschichte an.
Ja, weniger feiern, mehr zeigen.
Da habe ich immer,
ich bin da so ein bisschen
misstrauisch,
was sowas angeht.
Wenn es im Endeffekt
ja quasi ein
ein Durchschleifer ist
für USB,
also sprich,
das Ding tut so,
als wäre es ein USB,
also vermute ich mal,
dass das Ding so tut
gegenüber der Tastatur,
als wäre es ein USB-Hub
und gegenüber dem Rechner
so tut,
als wäre es eine USB-Tastatur.
Also quasi so,
so
Man in the Middle
USB,
sozusagen.
Also,
ich vermute einfach mal,
dass es so funktioniert.
Im Detail müssen wir mal gucken.
Da habe ich immer so
so diesen,
so dieses,
immer im Hinterkopf
hätte ich dann das Gefühl,
ich habe Input-Lag,
weil was dazwischen steckt.
Wahrscheinlich
sorgt das überhaupt
null für Input-Lag.
Aber das ist so
Mind-Game,
wisst ihr?
Ich würde jedes Mal denken,
ich habe Input-Lag.
Oder dann Keylogger.
Die Leute in Linus sind absolut Sell-Out.
Also,
ich würde jedes Mal, wenn ich ein Keylogger benutzen würde,
dass ich das nicht mehr wiederhabe.
Aber ich hätte es nicht mehr gefordert,
Profis, was, wie wäre es
mit diesem Keyboard
Excellent
das brauche ich
da kann man endlich mal ordentlich
binär programmieren
Excellent, das brauche ich
Exquisite Keyboard, das nehme ich
ich finde, was ich fast noch besser
finde, ist das
Control
Alt Delete Keyboard
für Windows
das da
das finde ich fast noch besser
Marc, was hast du gegen die Win32
API? Nix
Was soll ich gegen die Win32 API haben?
Specialty Precision Screwdrivers
Check it out today at ifixit.com
Bildschirmtastatur, genau, das ist die
Erklärung
Let me address a question that I get
so very often
Das ist geil
Moment, wartet mal
Das ist gut
Das gefällt mir
Gott
Alles markieren
Kopieren einfügen
Das ist gut, das gefällt mir
So ist es
So ist es aus
Vor allem, es passt auch dazu, dass es
PS2 ist
PS2, wahrscheinlich
ist es ja noch nicht im Jahr 2000 angekommen
Okay, auf
Jetzt zeigt mal hier die tolle Makrofunktion
von diesem Ding
Can't you just use multiple macro layers
on one keyboard?
Let me answer your question
with a question
When you board an airplane
do you peek inside the cockpit
and ask the pilot
Do you really need so many switches and buttons?
A single keyboard and mouse works fine
for Microsoft Flight Simulator
In both cases, the answer is the same
Having all of your controls
laid out like this
as a single layer of dedicated
keys with everything
clearly labeled
means that you can work more quickly
and more accurately
It just requires
more physical space
So, check this out
On the left, I'm using dedicated macro keys
to view the production calendar
Go to the graphics folder of my current project
to switch to Premiere
to add a specific effect
and to insert a specific sound
On the right, I'm doing the same thing
manually
without macro keys
It, uh
takes a lot longer
Ahem
Those seconds, really?
Can we fast forward this a little bit?
Okay, okay, thank you
Anyway, there are a lot of jobs that use
Gut, wenn man professioneller Video Editor ist
verstehe ich es, dass er das verleuchtet
voll ein
Just because I had to build and program
my own cockpit
doesn't mean it was a waste of time
Okay, so now that we've established
why someone might want
Er hat sehr spezifische Anforderungen
die er haben will
Ähm, da kann ich mich mit identifizieren
Ich hab ja auch immer so ganz spezielle Dinger
die ich, die ich haben will
und ich kauf dann auch nur was, was das, was das kann
A dedicated macro keyboard
Let's examine our options
and whoa-ho-ho
Oh, there's actually quite a few
Each with varying levels of difficulty
stability, functionality and price
If only someone could sort through all this stuff
and tell us which one is best for most people
So, in third place, we have a lot of stuff here
So, in third place, is the Corsair K55
At just $50, this is the cheapest of their offering
Ich will die K95 loswerden
Da verkauf ich mir jetzt ganz bestimmt keine K55
...that still supports IQ
Corsair's easy-to-use software
that allows for every key of a supported keyboard
to be reprogrammed
With IQ, you can create normal macros
or, because it supports F13 to F14
Was soll ich mir holen?
Den QWERTY Writer 2
Was ist das denn?
Hört sich schon mal an
Das ist schon mal abgedreht an
Pfff
Hahaha
Ist klar
Ah, yes
Schreibmaschine
Excellent
Da kann ich dann endlich meine
20 Romane drauf verfassen
Die ich schon im Kopf habe die ganze Zeit
Und noch nie zu Papier gebracht habe
Dafür brauche ich den QWERTY Writer
Unbedingt
So, gucken wir das Video weiter
Dann noch Pfeife und Monokel
Genau
Ich habe letztens auf Kickstarter
einen Monokel gesehen
Ich weiß nicht, ob das das war
Aber man kann auf Kickstarter Monokel, äh, äh, erfouten
Optimus Maximus wäre auch eine Tastatur
Hört sich an wie Transformer
In was kannst du dich verwandeln in eine Tastatur?
Was ist das?
Ich bin, ich bin mit meiner Ducky auch sehr zufrieden
Weil ich mir halt immer noch ohne
Ich war, ich war vorhin, war ich kurz davor
Ähm, mir eine weitere Ducky One Skyline zu kaufen
WTF?
Es ist alles nen, nen, nen
Alles nen, nen, nen Screen oder was?
Ja, das ist bestimmt sehr günstig zu haben
Ach, das ist ja
Ach ne, das ist irgendwas anderes
Ja, gucken wir mal weiter
F24
You can use this profile
And this always running auto hotkey script
To call powerful functions with parameters
Like the ones I demonstrated earlier
Ja, das geht aber nur bei Software wo auto hotkey funktioniert
Und ähm, es funktioniert halt nicht bei allem
Bei vielen Spielen geht auto hotkey mittlerweile nicht mehr
Und spätestens wenn man in der VM was machen möchte
Geht auto hotkey definitiv nicht
Make sure you check
Was genau soll die Tastatur alles können?
Eigentlich brauche ich ne, brauche ich nur in Anführungsstrichen
Ne ordentliche Tastatur zum Programmieren
Also sagen wir mal zum Schreiben
Und eine mit der man auch gut spielen kann
Und eine worauf es mir halt ankommt
Dass es dann ordentliche Makrofunktionen hat
Makro, nicht so sehr reine Makrofunktion
Ähm, also ich will nicht nur sagen
Eine Taste drückt für andere Tasten
Ich, ich, ich hätte schon gerne
Bisschen Betriebssystem Integration
So nach dem Motto
Wenn ich in dem Fenster bin
Dann das
Und wenn ich in dem Fenster bin
Dann vielleicht was anderes
Razer
Huh
This is my list
And this still surprised me
I've always found Razer Synapse really annoying to use
Sind dir die Keys egal?
Ich hab ehrlich gesagt
Außer
Äh
MX Speed
Switches
Und, und ich glaub Brown Switches
Ist standardmäßig in der Tachybon Skyline drin
Noch nichts anderes ausprobiert
Und
Die finde ich eigentlich beide ganz gut
But one of its best features
Is that it can distinguish between
Between multiple keyboards
And although it does not support F13 to F24
You can directly launch any file
From any key
Which includes auto hotkey scripts
That is incredibly useful
Oh and for your extra 10 bucks
You also get per key RGB lighting
Honestly the Cyanosa Chrome
Habe ich auch, brauche ich nicht
Is such a great deal for a pure macro keyboard
That I suspect for most of you
It'll be more than enough
So
If you wanna go this route
The Razer profile
All the auto hotkey code
And my instructional video
Can again be found in this video's description
Ich muss mal gucken wie viel Sterne das auf GitHub hat
Das interessiert mich jetzt
GitHub
Ho ho ho
Finally in first place
For just 63 dollars
From 1upkeyboards.com
You can get the Hasu USB Converter
Or as I call it
The ultimate macro device
The one that holds your mindgames in your back
So, so, so
Wie nennt man das
Nicht voreingenommen
Sondern immer
So aberglaubenmäßig
Immer im Hinterkopf
Dass ich irgendwie Input-Lag habe
Wenn ich sowas dazwischen hab
Paranoia, ja
Ja, das triffts ganz gut
Das triffts echt gut
Und gutes Gefühl
Paranoia triffts am besten
And that's a really big deal
Boutique, TMK und QMK-Keyboards kosten meistens über 100 US-Dollar insgesamt.
Ich hab übelst Hunger, ich hab noch nichts gegessen.
Aber ich bin noch nicht lange on, das heißt ich muss jetzt on bleiben.
Und wisst ihr was, Leute, wisst ihr was wir danach machen?
Ich hol mir gleich was zu essen, das dauert zwei Minuten oder drei Minuten.
Dann gucken wir ein nices Kochvideo zusammen auf YouTube und ich ess schnell was.
Willst du auch ein Wiener?
Ja, wenn du das jetzt schaffst irgendwie durch den Twitch-Chat zu pressen, dann würd ich einen nehmen.
Der hier kostet 15 US-Dollar, also egal.
Sollte man keine Funktastatur verwenden.
Das haben damals die Leute gesagt, lange bevor das rausgekommen ist, ja.
Unsere Leute sind halt clever.
Die sind alle richtig woke, wie man da so schön sagt.
Also nein, die sind einfach aufmerksam gewesen und haben gesagt,
Leute, sind ihr nicht so gut?
Das ist keine gute Idee, Arbeitsplätze mit Admin-Zugängen mit Funktastaturen auszustatten, ja.
Und damals hieß es so nach dem Motto, ah was, wir haben unsere Eingerätestrategie und das gibt jetzt die Tastatur.
Eineinhalb Jahre später, tja, jetzt stehen wir da.
Wer weiß, wie viele Admin-Passwörter schon abgegriffen wurden, dank der tollen Bluetooth-Lücke.
Shit happens, ja.
Pech gehabt.
Was ich da ganz lustig fand.
Ist, ähm, keine Two-Factor-Authentifizierung.
Es kommt drauf an, wofür.
Nicht bei allem.
Ja, bei so Sachen wie, ähm, lock dich auf einem IBM-Großrechner ein.
Da ist mit, die haben von Two-Factor-Authentifizierung noch nichts gehört.
Die Dinger sind aus dem Jahr 1984.
Also, basic-mäßig.
Unsere sind neuer, aber von dem, was da drin ist, ja.
Da ist mit Two-Factor-Authentifizierung nichts.
Du kommst schon von außen.
Du kommst von außen auch nicht dran.
Aber ich mein, man möchte trotzdem nicht, dass das Passwort mitgeschnitten wird.
Ja, zumindest, ich konnte ruhig und gewissens sagen, von mir hat keiner jemals irgendwas abgegriffen.
Weil ich hab, seit wir umgezogen sind und die mir diese komische Logitech-Tastatur hier antreten wollten,
hab ich mir ne Ducky One Skyline gekauft und hab meine Logitech G502 mitgenommen auf die Arbeit
und benutze die Kombination G502.
Plus Ducky One Skyline, alles mit Kabel, so wie sich das gehört.
Das heißt, wenn eine Admin-Passwörter abgegriffen hat, dann definitiv nicht von mir.
Eigentlich hätte ich jetzt mal hingehen müssen und sagen,
Jungs, ich hab schon vorgebeugt, krieg ich die Tastatur wenigstens ersetzt.
Oder bezahlt von euch.
Aber wisst ihr, was das merkwürdig ist in großen Firmen, wie ich arbeite?
Die verstehen bei sowas keinen Spaß.
Das sieht bei kleineren Läden anders aus.
Und zwar, wenn ich das denen jetzt nochmal extra unter die Nase gerieben hätte,
so nach dem Motto, ich hab quasi schon vorgesorgt und keine Tastatur genommen,
wo man Passwörter abgreifen kann, dann gäbe es ja zwei Varianten.
Entweder würde man sagen, Max, man hat jetzt gesehen, war keine schlechte Idee,
aber bei uns würde das anders laufen.
Bei uns würde es heißen, was?
Du verwendest ein Fremdgerät bei uns.
Das geht aber nicht.
Du musst unsere Kack-Logitech-Tastatur verwenden.
Das wäre die Logik bei uns gewesen, ey.
Richtig pepega.
Unabhängig davon, ob man da Sachen drüber abgreifen kann, vollkommen wurscht.
Ja, Quai, die Logik kennt jeder, der in ein bisschen größeren Laden arbeitet.
Die verstehen keinen Spaß bei sowas, ja?
Mit dem, das ist so 15 Dollar, also, was auch immer.
Aber wer kümmert sich um TMK und QMK?
Und was zum Teufel sind die?
Ich bin froh, dass du gefragt hast.
Sie sind open-source-Keyboard-Firmware, die für bestimmte Hardware designt sind,
wie die Teensy und das prionic-PCB.
Und obwohl ich immer an diese custom-Keyboards gedacht hätte,
als ein Spielzeug für Leute, die zu viel Geld haben und kein Wissen über Auto-Hotkey haben,
ist es so, dass nur ein Teil davon wahr ist.
Huge Joke.
Nein, ernsthaft.
Es gibt viele coole Sachen in hier, die wirklich zu einem bestimmten Punkt abhängen werden,
die wirklich zu einem bestimmten Nerd abhängen.
Das bringt mir alles nichts, wenn ich nicht erkennen kann, in welcher Anwendung ich bin.
So, ein Beispiel mal.
Weil sich wahrscheinlich viele fragen, Max, warum willst du erkennen können, in welcher Anwendung du bist?
Ganz einfach.
Zum Beispiel, wenn ich hier rüber switche auf meine VM,
will ich, dass der automatisch da rein und raus gehen kann.
Also sprich, wenn ich mein Desktop-Switch-Makro drücke,
ich habe das hier leider nicht drauf,
das habe ich auf meinem Main-Account,
wenn ich beispielsweise mein Desktop-Switch-Makro drücke, Taste drücke,
dann macht er automatisch, wenn er in der VM drin ist,
macht er automatisch Ctrl-Alt und drückt für mich danach nach 200 Millisekunden
Ctrl-Windows-Taste-File-Taste.
So.
Umgekehrt, wenn ich rüber switche auf die VM,
dann muss er für mich Alt-V drücken,
zweimal nach unten und Enter für Exclusive Mode.
Weil das vor allem mal so scheiße gemacht hat.
Das sind so Sachen, die will ich mit meiner Makro-Software machen,
deswegen brauche ich eine Makro-Software,
die ein bisschen mit dem Betriebssystem zusammenhängt,
dass man zum Beispiel erkennen kann, in welcher Anwendung man drin ist.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob wir hier irgendwas dafür schon gebastelt haben.
Gucken wir mal, ob ich hier irgendeine Makro-Sache schon drin habe.
Äh, Moment, wie ging das hier überhaupt nochmal?
Geht das nicht mit Auto-Hotkey?
Nee, das geht nicht mit Auto-Hotkey.
Makro 1.
Alter, diese Software, die macht mich fertig.
Wo konnte man den Kram denn hier nochmal anklicken?
Actions.
Genau.
Hier, guckt Leute.
Wir haben das eben probiert.
Der geht jetzt, der geht quasi raus hier, drückt das,
und geht dann rüber.
Und das geht halt nur, wenn man checken kann,
äh, also nur mit einer Taste, wenn man checken kann,
in welcher Anwendung man drin ist und sowas.
Was hier jetzt nicht geht.
Sowas will ich halt mit der Makro-Software machen.
Ich will die, also ein Ziel, was ich hab, ist halt,
dass die Zusammenarbeit zwischen Linux und Windows hier nebeneinander
so problemlos wie irgendwie möglich funktioniert.
Mit der Logitech-Software funktioniert das richtig gut, ja.
Geht das nicht mit Auto-Hotkey?
Nee, mit Auto-Hotkey geht das nicht.
Weil Auto-Hotkey kann zum Beispiel keine Tastatureingaben in eine VM senden.
Geht nicht.
Weil,
weil,
VM, wer quasi keine Windows-Tastatureingaben entgegennimmt,
sondern irgendein Low-Level, äh, Keyboard,
äh, USB-Treiber, Hook, was auch immer hat,
und die sich überhaupt nicht dafür interessieren,
was, äh, Windows für Tastatureingaben schickt.
Kauft doch einfach eine Logitech-Tastatur.
Das würde ich machen.
Ich hab noch keine Logitech-Tastatur gefunden, die mir gefällt.
Schahl mal rein!
Ist das,
ist das, ist das irgendwie, ist das...
ist da dann Arduino drin, oder was ist das?
Das sieht mir irgendwie sehr nach, nach so, Arduino-Zweig.
Ich mein, das ist C, ja, aber äh, C++ ist es.
Das sieht mir ein bisschen nach...
Wie heißt dieses Ding nochmal?
Hasu USB.
Ist das ein Arduino drin?
Willst du deutsches oder englisches Layout?
Deutsches.
CPU, was ist denn da drauf?
Nee, Cheat 100.
Ich will das einfach benutzen.
Ich will jetzt nicht das Rad neu erfinden.
Plus, dass ich zwischen Desktop switchen kann.
Ist da ein ESP drin?
Was ist denn da drin?
Ah, weiß nicht.
Carpet.
Gibt es eigentlich eine Tastatur, die das Gegenteil von Steuerung Z macht?
Ja, entweder Steuerung Y oder Shift-Ctrl-Z.
Kommt ein bisschen auf die Software an.
Hast du mit Auto-Hotkey mal geschaut, ob das nicht geht?
Ja, hab ich.
Das war das erste, was ich ausprobiert habe.
Warte mal einen Moment.
Ja gut.
Das hat...
Logischerweise keinerlei Betriebssystem-Schnittstelle, weil es ist ja eine extra Hardware.
Ohne Software auf dem Host-Rechner drauf.
Ey, du wirst lachen auf meinem, äh, quasi auf meinem Main-Windows-Profil, was ich verwende,
wenn ich nicht streame, mache ich das Switchen sogar mit der Logitech-Maus.
Weil die Logitech-Makro-Software eigentlich die beste ist.
... oder QMK ist kapabel.
Also, der bessere Weg, das zu tun, ist, eine Linux-Environment zu erstellen,
in Windows, install Git, und dann den gesamten QMK-Repository zu downloaden.
Ja.
It's easy.
Dann bist du bereit, einen Text-Editor zu nutzen.
Na, okay, der macht das jetzt auch so ein bisschen lustig, aber wahrscheinlich ist es wirklich nicht schwierig,
wenn man ein bisschen was in der Richtung schon gemacht hat.
Um den richtigen Keymap.c-File zu modifizieren, und vielleicht auch den Config.h,
launchen wir Ubuntu, CD über zu unserem QMK-Firmware-Folder und machen uns ein Hex-File.
... und machen uns ein Hex-File.
Now, I have a full tutorial video for that, too.
It's linked below.
But don't worry, you don't have to do any of that stuff,
because you can find several Hex-Files that I already created for you on my GitHub, also linked below.
I recommend f24.hex, but if you want Ctrl, Shift and Alt to still work normally,
use f24withmodifiers.hex.
Bringing us finally to...
Ich dachte, er zeigt ein bisschen mehr, was man mit dem Gerät...
Ich kann so ein Ding nicht dazwischenstecken.
Ich hab bei jedem Game Komplexe, dass ich Input-Lag hab.
Geht nicht.
Ah, das ist ein Arduino. Guck mal.
Oder zumindest was Arduino-ähnliches.
Das ist ein ATmega23...
ATmega sind ja diese...
Die Arduino-Dinger.
Also ich vermute mal ganz stark, dass das irgendwas...
Zumindest Arduino-ähnliches sein wird, was da drauf ist.
Einfach zwei Tastaturen, eine zum Spielen, eine zum Programmieren.
Du wirst lachen, das hab ich mir schon tatsächlich überlegt,
aber ich will keine zwei Tastaturen hier rumstehen haben.
Ich hab ja auch eine Tastatur für zwei Rechner, hier.
Wozu soll ich für jeden Rechner eine Tastatur hinstellen?
Ich kann einfach Maus scheren.
Maus-Tastatur scheren.
... in your keyboard to the back, or it won't work.
And sometimes you might have to replug it in after a computer restart,
which is pretty annoying.
Now, if you were to go and type into a text document at this stage,
you'd probably notice that it's still sending normal keystrokes,
except the caps lock doesn't work.
So what gives?
Well, I lied earlier.
You're not quite done.
Next, you'll need to download and install AutoHotKey.
Then, go to this link and download this AutoHotKey script by clicking RAW and CTRL-X to save it.
Doch, äh, wenn die Tasten nicht standard groß sind,
glaube ich nicht, dass ich damit klarkomme.
Mich nerven ja schon die etwas zu rutschigen Tasten auf der K95.
Also, wenn das alles, was nicht standard ist...
... weiß nicht.
... aber ich guck's mir mal an.
... und save it here.
Delete the stupid .txt if it appears.
Now, double-click on it to get it running.
A friendly icon should appear in your taskbar.
Aber AutoHotKey kann ich nicht verwenden.
Now, try typing into a text document.
Instead of text, you should be seeing tooltips, no matter which key you press.
Perfect.
Ich kann kein AutoHotKey verwenden.
Also erstens, weil mit AutoHotKey nicht funktioniert, was ich machen will,
was hier das Switchen angeht und sowas.
Und zweitens, weil mit AutoHotKey nicht funktioniert, was ich machen will, was hier das Switchen angeht und sowas.
Das größte Problem ist aber, dass in vielen Spielen AutoHotKey entweder die Spiele nicht starten
oder nicht richtig als Cheat erkannt werden.
Wobei hauptsächlich die Spiele nicht starten, wenn man AutoHotKey anhat.
Das ist doof.
... to you. All you have to do is replace those tooltips with literally any script you want.
You can do anything that AutoHotKey can do, which is a lot.
Oh, I probably should have mentioned that you should already know how to use AutoHotKey
before you add a second keyboard.
So, if you're new, this is a great tutorial to get you started.
Also, I strongly recommend that you place a shortcut to the script file into your startup folder like so.
But why do it this way?
Why not just create the macros inside of QMK?
Well, because AutoHotKey can do a thousand times as much stuff.
So, for my purposes, I just need a little way...
AutoHotKey can do a thousand times as much stuff.
The other thing is that you can program yourself in C,
so you can definitely do just as much with it.
So, purely keyboard-wise.
Interaction with the operating system, of course not.
But, as I said, that...
doesn't help me, because
what I need when AutoHotKey doesn't work,
and AutoHotKey in games often causes problems.
... for my QMK keyboard...
I know, I sometimes think I'm the only one in the world who has problems like that.
... call any of the functions that I'd already written in AutoHotKey.
And, because I couldn't figure out how to send PS2 Set 1 Make scan codes,
or raw USB keyboard HID codes...
Ah, kack noob.
... I had to go with my usual method of using F24 as an extra modifier key.
I call this wrapping a keystroke.
Then I use this single line in AutoHotKey
to block those wrapped keystrokes and replace...
Ehe, gleich. Müssen wir uns das jetzt weiter angucken.
Lohnt sich, glaube ich nicht, dass ich damit das machen kann, was ich machen will.
Das ist natürlich blöd.
Aber...
So, was ich jetzt mal gucken wollte, ist eigentlich, was sagt denn...
Bevor wir uns die ganzen anderen Tastaturen angucken,
was sagt denn eigentlich die PC Games Hardware dazu,
was das für... was Tastaturen beste sind?
Hol dir jetzt dein Essen. Sehr gute Idee.
Wir können schon mal überlegen, was wir für ein Kochvideo ko...
Was gucken wir denn?
Cooking...
Ich gucke kein Gordon Ramsay, das sage ich euch gleich.
Äh...
Cooking...
Äh... Korean.
Korean Food.
Wir gucken uns Koreanisch an.
How to make Korean Bulgogi.
Bibimbap.
Ey, wir gucken Dings hier.
Da gibt es doch diesen Steak Test Channel.
Die immer so Steaks ausprobieren.
Was... Klaus grillt.
Was ist Klaus grillt?
Ah, stimmt.
Ich habe überhaupt nichts.
Hallo, willkommen...
Grillt der auch wirklich?
Hallo, willkommen bei Klaus grillt Feinsgrill.
...
Nee, das ist mir zu wenig kochen.
Das ist zu wenig kochen.
So, ich will irgendwas koreanisches gucken.
Korean Bulgogi.
Korean Crab.
What the fuck?
Moment.
Sieht das nur so aus?
Oder ist das sehr Thumbnail vorteilhaft programmiert?
Äh, was laber ich?
Programmiert, Alter.
Äh, aufgenommen.
Ich glaube, das ist sehr vorteilhaft für ein Thumbnail aufgenommen.
Dollsort Bibimbap.
Ah, das sieht gut aus.
Das sieht gut aus.
Koreanische Oma kocht.
Was soll da schief gehen?
Hello, everybody.
Hello.
Everybody.
Koreanische Oma kocht.
Da kann nichts schief gehen.
Was haben wir sonst noch zu bieten?
Best Ramen Soup.
Best Ramen Recipe.
How to best.
Den gucken wir uns jetzt an.
Ich meine, wir können uns jetzt schützen.
Er wird alles machen, außer Ramen kochen.
Seriös?
Soweit, das ist, will ich hier nicht hören, boink.
Er ist
Er will nachboten.
Lass uns ab.
Aber wahrscheinlich kennen die meisten.
Ich meine, guck mal, der hat wie viel?
14 Millionen Subscriber, Alter.
Wann geht's denn los?
Okay, ich spule mal ein bisschen vor.
Das ist übelst abgedreht, die Videos von dem Kerl.
Okay, wir werden echt krass debatet.
Aber lange kann das immer dauern.
Okay, es geht schon los.
Ich sag doch, die Videos gehen auf einmal in eine sehr merkwürdige Richtung.
Jetzt fehlt bloß noch das Ei.
Das Ei kommt garantiert auch wieder.
Wie viele Nudeln?
Viele.
Da kommt noch irgendwas.
Das kann doch nicht alles sein.
Also das Ei muss mal mindestens da einmal...
Oder er springt jetzt rein oder irgendwie sowas.
Da springt er jetzt rein.
Irgendwas muss da jetzt noch kommen.
Es wird immer mehr Nudeln.
Ist der Agur?
Wie?
Bis jetzt ist noch wirklich nichts passiert.
Das kann eigentlich überhaupt nicht sein.
Der muss sich jetzt da drin rumrollen oder sowas noch.
Okay, er hat es echt übertrieben.
Wird er...
Krasser Scherz.
Genau, nackig muss er auch noch durch die Wohnung laufen.
Der Kerl hat so einen Knall.
Aber das Video ist für ihn echt harmlos.
Oh, nee.
Okay, aber das Video ist für den Typ echt harmlos.
Normalerweise ist das deutlich ekliger.
Okay, Leute.
Ich hole mir jetzt was zu essen.
Mal gucken, was ein Kochvideo an.
Ich bin gleich wieder da.
Von jedem mal mindestens ein Krippel.
Please im Chat.
Mit Leinen am Start.
So.
Ich bin da am Start.
So, jetzt essen wir erstmal schnell was.
Dabei gucken wir uns an.
Von Kotsuramen Basics mit Babish.
So, dann zeige ich euch was.
Babish.
Ich habe von dem noch nie was gesehen.
Basics with Babish.
Basics with Babish.com
Brought to you by Squarespace.
Head there now to check out recipes.
Squarespace.
Big, big.
Spray and sell out.
Machen ganz viele jetzt.
So.
Aber, aber.
Whether you need a domain, website, or online store, make your next move with Squarespace.
Alright, folks.
So far in previous episodes, we've covered how to make Tonkatsu Ramen Broth from scratch.
I'm boiling pork bones and aromatics for 12 hours.
And we've covered how to make Chashu Pork Belly in our sous vide.
Or at least we've gotten it started.
You can find links to these techniques in this video's description.
Once you got that stuff out of the way, we can soldier on to our remaining.
I hope you enjoyed some time.
So, we're almost at the end of our video here.
All we have left to do now is to..
Check out our website, subscribe to our channel, like us on Facebook, trên Facebook.
You can find us here, we're up to date.
Make sure that you give this video a card, so that it will stay connected to that video,
as sometimes we can'tこちら it.
So please do aρέcht, eDeal.
So don't get upset
and comment on my channel,
you'll be very happy.
Ciao.
Bye.
einzigen michelin sternen die einzigen michelin stern instant rahmen suppe aus japan bestellt
aber viel zu teuer durch durch hin und her schicken und alles wobei man sagen muss dass
die die suppe hat kein stern sondern also die suppe hat er der der koch in dem restaurant
hat halt den stern nicht die inszenz suppe kennst du alex den french guy
und letting these guys
überlegt hat wie das hieß was ich bestellt hatte
irgendwie super rahmen zutat zutat soba soba soba soba instant zutat ja
das da genau
da hatte ich mir so ein pack bestellt das problem ist halt dass das mit versand und
import viel zu teuer ist ich meine es ist die beste instant nudelsuppe die ich je gegessen
habe aber es ist der instant nudelsuppe ja schau dir mal was raimund an jetzt
eigentlich was essen jetzt amazon oder wo kauft man die amazon koreanische rahmen suppe scharf 20
könnte man sich mal geben ja finde ich gut
das ist gar nichts
solaris
solar von astor
so
das ist
ja
da
ist
ja
aber
ich glaube
ja
At 250 degrees Fahrenheit for one hour.
This changes the pH balance of our baking soda and turns it into a mild skin irritant, so make sure not to touch it.
We're combining two teaspoons of our baked soda with four ounces plus two tablespoons of water.
Alter Fahrenheit, ja.
Make sure to dissolve completely.
Triggert mich schon wieder.
Wir können nicht gescheite Einheiten verwenden.
To which we are adding our alkaline water mixture and combining with a wooden or other spoon.
We want a shaggy but cohesive ball of dough.
And as you can see, this is a little bit too dry, so I'm going to add a little bit of extra water.
Think pasta dough in terms of consistency.
Once it comes together into a cohesive but not sticky ball of dough, we're going to pat it into a disc,
dust it with bread flour and cover, letting rest for one half an hour.
Nee, ich würde eher sagen, England.
Take this time to go clean up your apron, because you've made a mess of yourself.
And then once half an hour has elapsed, extract the dough from the bowl and then it's time to start rolling out.
We're going to start by performing a single rudimentary lamination,
that is lightly diluted.
Dusting with flour, rolling out, and folding into thirds like a letter.
Then into thirds again, so not quite like a letter.
But hey, I'm not going to judge you for how you fold your letters.
We're rolling this out just a little bit.
Kekona Masa.
Last grab and letting rest again for another half hour.
We're just letting the gluten relax before we break out the big guns.
That's right, it's time to bust out your shiny new stand mixer pasta roller.
You know, the one you got for Christmas.
I think that's the only way you can actually get one of these, as a Christmas or wedding gift.
Anyway, we're going to give this guy one final lamination before...
Rolling him out and cutting him up.
What's he doing there? I have no idea what he's doing.
I thought he wanted to make soup.
What's he actually doing there?
You know what? Rotating 90 degrees and beginning to roll out ever thinner until we're at about a two or three.
I'm too busy with my food, but...
If the edges are too ragged, I'll just go ahead and...
Ah, noodles!
Ah, Chad.
Chad is here with a...
...full Aufmerksam dabei.
...for dusting of bread flour before the most satisfying part of our day running this...
Oh, nice.
A nice noodle.
...to little ramen nests on a bread flour dusted rimmed baking sheet.
At this point, these can be refrigerated or frozen.
I'm just going to cover mine with plastic wrap...
So obvious ist das nicht, wenn du nicht hinguckst.
Das letzte, wo ich hingeguckt habe, hat er irgendwas in der Pfanne gemacht und auf einmal macht er einen Teig.
Hast du schon eine neue Tastatur gefunden?
Nee, wir müssen noch ein paar Sachen durchgucken.
Mmmh.
Was ist das?
Mmmh, nice.
...this in awe for a moment.
And then we're going to snip up the string and slice this...
Das kann bestimmt auch so enden.
Now, ideally you want to chill this overnight so you can get it nice and firm and cut...
Ah, das ist hier Schweinebauch, oder was ist das?
...but I'm really hungry.
So, into some boiling water go the ramen noodles.
We're not letting those cook for more than three minutes.
Wir machen da immer Schweinebauch rein.
And I'm going to test for doneness after about 90 seconds.
Das ist Schweinebauch hier.
...a few tablespoons of our tare, followed by a few ladles of steaming hot broth,
followed by our freshly cooked and rigorously shook noodles.
Dump those guys into the broth.
There we go.
And now it's time to get all dressed up with nowhere to go.
Into the back of the bowl goes one to two slices of our chashu pork.
Wenn ihr noch ein geiles Video sehen wollt, guckt ihr das Lasagne-Video an.
Then we're slicing in half one of our beautifully soft boiled noodles.
Mach ich, ich brauch noch ein bisschen, bis ich fertig gefruddert hab.
...on to the other side, a handful of scallions optionally,
and I like a few pieces of spicy menma or fermented bamboo shoots.
Mmm, das Ei sieht gut aus.
Also das würde ich mir jetzt...
Ich würde mir das instant reinhauen.
Warte mal kurz, warte mal kurz.
Bisschen hoch machen.
Das sieht gut aus.
Ah, yes, Squarespace.
Okay, ähm, gucken wir uns die Lasagne noch an.
Babisch.
Was?
La-sa-gne.
Schreibt man das so?
Lasagna.
Welches davon?
Das da?
Das obere?
Lasagne from Garfield?
Welches ist das richtige?
Ja, das obere ist da, okay.
Gibt es wirklich Leute, die Mixed Feelings about Lasagne haben?
Ich kenne keinen, der nicht zumindest Lasagne essen kann.
Hey, was ist los, Leute? Willkommen zurück bei Binging with Babisch,
wo wir gerade Ricotta mit Brat und Tee gemacht haben.
Wir machen jetzt Ragu-Bolognese, für die wir 1 Pound pro Kilo Pfeffer,
Fleisch und Veal brauchen.
Der klassische Mehlball-Mix.
Wir werden den Pott übergeben.
Wir werden nicht nur das Fett rausnehmen, sondern wir werden auch später mit der Sauce konsumieren.
Wir werden den Pott mit ein wenig Reservier-Fett machen,
das heißt, 1 gechoppte Zwiebel, 1 große gechoppte Karotte und ein paar Stöcke gechopptes Salat.
Ein paar optionalen Schaken von roter Pfeffer, wenn ihr ein wenig Wärme benötigt wollt,
und ein guter Schlauch von Oregano.
Lasst die Farben miteinander kennen,
vermengt, lasst die Zwiebeln sich öffnen
und dann krümmt ihr 4 Zwiebeln mit Gerleik,
sautiert für nur einen weiteren Minuten, bis es frisch ist,
weil wir eine wunderschöne Schale haben, die auf dem Boden dieses Pottes entsteht.
Wenn du ein Dumm-Dumm bist, wirst du das Fleisch zurück in den Pott geben
und dann mit dem Wein de-glazen.
Was du tun willst, ist, mit dem Wein de-glazen und dann mit dem Pott reingepackt werden.
Sprinkle all das leckere, gute Sachen.
Und dann 2 Kupfen von Homemade-Chickenstock oder Chicken Stock,
die wir jetzt auch von einem Packet von Gelatine haben.
Jetzt ist es Tomatensaison.
Wir befinden uns ziemlich nah an der alten Version des Rezepts von J. Kenji López.
Also, ein paar Zwiebeln, so dass es einfach wie 100 Zwiebeln zu den restlichen Sachen geht.
Wir werden auch ein paar Spritzen frischer Basil hinzufügen
und nicht ein paar Spritzen frischer Zwiebeln hinzufügen.
Stöcke das Ganze ab, stelle es nicht in einen Haufen, wie ich es gemacht habe.
Zusammen mit einer Kuppe und einer halben Milch.
Stöcke es ein wenig auf,
gebe 2 Zwiebeln hinzu.
Mache sicher, dass alles einigermaßen verspürt und untergebracht ist.
Und es ist Zeit, das Ganze für ca. 4 Stunden langsam zu zimmern.
Alternativ könnt ihr es mit dem Lid teilweise offen machen,
in einem 325°F-Oven für ca. 4 Stunden.
Also, Leute, das könnte man auch so essen, oder?
Ein paar Nudeln dabei und gut ist.
Schön dick und reich und relativ kohäsiv.
Lass uns unsere Zwiebeln und Basil hinzufügen.
Nehme eine halbe Kuppe frischer Basil hinzu.
Und habe eine halbe Kuppe frischer Basil hinzufügen.
Wir werden auch eine 3 oz. Parmesan hinzufügen.
Oder eine halbe Pfanne.
Jep.
Misch alles zusammen.
Oh, ich will jetzt...
Ich...
Ohne Scheiß, Leute, scheiß auf mein Brot.
Ich hätte jetzt gerne mal so eine ordentliche Portion Nudeln
mit irgendwie Bolognese-Soße
und irgendwie so einem halben Liter Parmesan-Käs drauf.
Melter, kohäsiv, reich und lecker und...
Oh Gott, das ist gut.
Aber wie immer...
Nico, zuerst Dankeschön.
... mit Salz und frischem Pfeffer hinzufügen.
Ihr werdet es wahrscheinlich traurig hören,
aber wartet bis zum Ende, um eure Saucen und Suppen zu saugen.
Und so weiter.
Bevor ihr alle eure Saucen und Suppen trinkt,
verwendet diesen Kerl auf dem Backburner,
denn jetzt ist es Zeit, frische Pasta zu machen.
Es ist nicht unser erstes Mal, Pasta auf dem Show zu machen.
Wenn ihr wollt, wie ihr Pasta von außen machen könnt,
schaut euch das Basics-Episode an.
Ich mache hier einfach nur das Grandma-Ding.
Ich habe hier eine Menge Pfeffer, eine Menge Eier,
ein bisschen Salz, und mische sie alle zusammen.
Nun, normalerweise ist das Problem, dass ich mein Brot überhydratiert habe.
Und dieses Mal habe ich es überhydratiert.
Also es ist sehr, sehr gut.
Ich hatte nur ein paar große, starke Hände, um mir mit diesem zu helfen.
Große, starke Hände, sagst du, Babish?
Steig' weg.
Oh, schau, es ist ein wirklich großer Kerl namens Brad.
Aber es sieht so aus, als ob gerade Brad mit mir zusammengekommen wäre.
Es ist viel mit Brad zusammengekommen, er hat eine wirklich schwierige Zeit mit diesem Brot.
Es ist sehr überhydratiert.
Aber keine Sorge, wir haben dafür eine Lösung.
Für den Moment schneiden wir das Brot in vier gleiche Teile
und packen es in Plastik, lassen es sich auf Raumtemperatur für 30 Minuten lassen
und fangen an, mit einem Pasta-Roller zu rollen.
Nun, wenn euer Brot unterhydratiert ist,
werdet ihr sehen, dass das anfängt zu passieren.
Die Ecken, wenn ihr es durch die Pasta-Maschine drückt,
werden ausgetrocknet und zerstört.
Die Lösung ist es, das Brot wieder mit etwas Wasser zu knöpfen.
Ich meine, ja, wir könnten Wasser verwenden, aber, äh,
wir haben alle diese Wege von der Ricotta-Maschine übrig,
das Biprodukt der Ricotta.
Wir sollten das vielleicht dazu geben, um das Brot zu knöpfen,
um das Brot zu knöpfen, um das Brot zu knöpfen,
um das Brot zu knöpfen, um das Brot zu knöpfen.
Und wir müssen es essen, wir müssen es essen.
Between the sheets with Babish and Brad coming soon.
Now I am decidedly in the anti-ricotta in lasagna camp, but I'm going to trust that this is going to work out.
So Brad, what do you say we go ahead and bake this thing?
Oh yeah, we got the oven set to 375, we got a little parmesan top.
Ordentlich, ordentlich Parmesan, so muss das sein.
And throw this bad boy in on a little sheet tray.
Smart move there, Babi.
Kennt ihr das, wenn ihr irgendwie Nudel Bolognese oder so esst,
dass die Hälfte, wenn nicht sogar drei Viertel gefühlt von dem, was ihr gegessen habt,
am Ende aus Parmesan-Käse bestanden haben?
Ich schmeiß da immer gefühlt einen halben Liter oder so drauf.
Ich mach immer extra ein neues Päckchen auf, wenn ich Bolognese-Soße futter.
Und ich sag dann, okay, probier's dir erstmal so, probier's dir erstmal so.
Denk ich so, ah, schmeckt ja auch so, gar nicht so schlecht, gar nicht so schlecht.
Und irgendwann, so nach ein paar Mal Essen, nach ein paar Mal, ne, paar Portionen gefuttert,
sag ich dann so.
Denk ich mir immer, ey, machst du ein bisschen, machst du ein bisschen Parmesan-Käse, machst du ein bisschen,
ich reib, ich reib den Parmesan-Käse nicht.
Nee, selbst, das ist fertig aus der, aus der Tüte.
So, und dann mach ich ein bisschen Parmesan drauf, aber sobald ich Parmesan-Käse draufgeschmissen hab,
muss ich ja quasi nach jedem Mal, nach jedem, nach jedem Löffel, nach jeder Gabel,
muss ich, muss ich neuen Parmesan-Käse draufschreiben, draufschmeißen.
Sie heißt,
ist sie heiß, hä?
Wenn nicht, übernachtlich.
Und nach den längsten 30 Minuten unserer Leben, ist es Zeit, reinzubeißen.
Und wie ihr vielleicht erwartet habt, hat es einen verdammten Cheese-Stretch.
Topp es mit einem zartem Basil-Liefen, und, weißt du, wir müssen hier aufhören, um das zu machen.
Nimm ein Blatt, okay? Du bist Teil des Teams.
Weil Lasagne sollte als Familie genutzt werden.
Jetzt muss ich sagen, für das erste Mal, dass ich die Inklusion von Ricotta in das nicht hasse.
Ja, es ist, ich meine, es ist cheesig, du weißt, die Mozzarella ist schön, es hat einen schönen Stretch dazu.
Aber ich sage dir was, das kleine Kleine da drüben, ist die Ricotta.
Ich brauche noch mehr zu essen, Leute. Das war zu wenig.
So ein Brötchen.
Ich würde nicht mehr mit jemand anderem Lasagne machen.
Das ist nix.
Ich brauche mehr.
Ich hätte mir keine Kochvideos angucken sollen. Ich brauche mehr essen, Leute.
Zu wenig.
Kriege ich jetzt noch mehr zu essen? Ja.
Egal. Das muss ich jetzt aushalten.
Was? AliExpress? Was geht mit denen ab?
Kleiner, süßer Skorpion.
Skorpion.
Weil Skorpione ja auch bekannt dafür sind, dass sie so klein und süß sind, ne?
Ja, der DTK, ganz bestimmt.
Okay, da speichern wir nochmal.
Also, Tastatur, wo sind wir stehen geblieben?
Was sagt denn die PC Games Hardware zu Tastaturen?
Die empfiehlt mir die Tastatur, die ich loswerden will.
Ja, super. Toll.
Ne, was ist was anderes?
Moment, die sehen sich einfach nur so ähnlich.
Die sehen sich einfach nur so ähnlich.
Also, RGB-Crap da.
Okay, was haben wir hier zu sehen?
Testsieger, Coolmaster MK850, Ducky Shine.
Warum hat die so eine Kackwertung auf...
Nachteile? Keine. Das glaube ich nicht. Alles hat irgendwie Nachteile.
Was für eine Tastatur willst du haben?
Ja, was zum Schreiben, also zum Programmieren und was zum Spielen.
Und vor allem eine ordentliche Makro-Software.
Warum möchtest du die Corsana loswerden?
Weil... Ich fasse dir das jetzt nochmal kurz zusammen.
Ich habe sie nämlich auf Twitter schon geschrieben.
Unter anderem... Ich habe es vorher noch ein bisschen ausführlicher erklärt.
Unter anderem, weil das Ding doppelte Tastenanschläge hat, weil es ein komisches Layout hat,
weil ich immer mit dem Finger zwischen Steuerung und Funktionstaste rutsche,
dass die Tastenoberfläche mir zu rutschig ist, dass die Tasten wackeln,
dass das Ding bei mir massig Staub und Dreck einfängt
und dass die Software im Hintergrund permanent CPU-Leistung frisst.
Auf der A-Pile habe ich eine Ducky One Skyline, mit der bin ich auch zufrieden.
Allerdings hat die keine ordentliche Makro-Software.
Sonst würde ich mir noch eine kaufen.
Du kennst keines von diesen Problemen?
Ja, vielleicht hast du die Probleme auch nicht.
Das ist ja was Individuelles, ja?
Außer mit doppelten Tastenanschlägen.
Michael, nachdem... Das habe ich hier irgendwo auch schon drinnen stehen.
Das Ding.
Kost?
Geht doch eigentlich.
So, warte mal. Was, was...
Was sagen die denn dazu?
Wo ist eigentlich meine gelandet?
Hier.
KV90 RGB Platinum, 8er Platz.
Äh...
Alter, die Musik. Was ist da los?
Ah, das ist auch Carina of Time.
Oder?
Ja, ich glaube schon.
Das stand hier unten, glaube ich, gerade.
Das Vorschaubild der Stream-Ankündigung.
Ah, das Kochvideo!
Ja, wir haben ja gedacht,
wenn ich jetzt schon euch was vorfutter,
dann kann ich wenigstens ein Kochvideo anmachen.
Das Problem ist, ich habe jetzt noch mehr Hunger.
Ich will eine mechanische Tastatur.
Okay, also, was ist an der Tastatur so toll?
Cool Master. Was? Was sagen sie?
Also, man muss ja sagen...
Ah, vielleicht sollte ich das mal ausmachen.
Sieht ein bisschen besser aus.
Cherry MX Red RGB.
Was hat meine?
Cherry MX Speed RGB.
Was hat meine? Cherry MX Speed RGB.
Was ist denn der Unterschied zwischen Red und Speed?
Was sagst du zur G910?
Hab ich noch nicht angeguckt.
Makrospeicher, USB, okay, bla bla.
Lautstärke?
Welche davon ist lauter?
Rocket, ich will mir eigentlich keine Rocket kaufen.
Ah, hier.
Also, was? Nur mal so.
Ihr kennt euch da wahrscheinlich.
Wahrscheinlich habt ihr ein paar Pros.
Ich habe ja so eine auf der Arbeit.
Was ist denn da standardmäßig drin? Brown, oder? Brown-Splitter.
Brown-Splitter.
Ah, die Musik, was ist jetzt los?
Blue? Red?
Ich muss mal kurz gucken bei Amazon, was ich mir gekauft habe.
So, jetzt muss ich mich nur einloggen.
Passwort ist incorrect.
Warum?
Warum ist das Passwort incorrect?
Nee, geht doch.
Ähm...
Ducky...
Mist, die habe ich nicht über Amazon gekauft.
Fuck.
Jetzt weiß ich nicht, was ich für Switches habe.
Blue Switches? Ich habe keine Ahnung, was ich für Switches habe.
Du kannst eine Tastenkappe von deiner Tastatur abnehmen.
Das bringt mir nichts, die habe ich auf der Arbeit.
Hier habe ich eine K95 Platinum,
die will ich ja loswerden.
Welche...
Ich habe hier die K95 hier.
Und das sind ja angeblich MX Speed.
So.
Mit MX Speed sind das
Clicky-Tasten,
taktile Tasten,
lineare Tasten.
Also man...
So einen richtigen Klick hört man nicht.
Man hört an der Stelle...
Wenn man unten ankommt halt.
Ja, ich glaube auch, dass ich Brown Switches habe.
Lineare sind die, okay.
Was ist so euer Favorit?
Davon?
Wichtig, ich muss Straven spammen.
Nee, macht Sinn.
Also Brown ist doch eher taktil.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Ich weiß nur, dass sie deutlich mehr klicken,
als die Tastatur, die ich hier daheim habe.
Brown mit Rings, genau das habe ich auch.
Exakt.
Das habe ich auch bei meiner Ducky One.
Genau, ich habe browne Switches
und diese Silikonringe drunter.
Zum Zocken rot und
Kompromiss ist braun.
Also wäre ein brown Switch
für mich ganz gut, oder?
Weil ich ja...
relativ viel tippen,
schreiben, aber auch spielen.
Ein paar Switches anhören.
Oh, da gibt es ein Zuhörvideo.
Typing Sounds.
Krass, was es alles
gibt für Videos.
Wobei ich ehrlich sagen muss,
du spielst Shooter hauptsächlich,
ja, aber ich spiele alles mögliche.
Aber wenn es auf Competitive Aspect ankommt,
dann Shooter. Wobei ich sagen muss,
die linearen Tasten hier daheim,
die finde ich nicht verkehrt.
Wenn MXB,
die lineare sind.
Die haben keinen Klick.
Die machen null Klick.
Wenn ich da nicht anhaue,
also wenn ich die einfach nur runter drücke,
dann höre ich keinen Klick.
Das finde ich eigentlich ganz gut,
muss ich sagen.
Weil ich bin ja hier auch
manchmal früh auf, mache spät auf.
Ich will gar nicht so sehr auf die Tasten
hier hauen.
Also auf der Arbeit muss ich sagen,
es sind die brown Switches von der Ducky One Skyline
ganz erträglich. Aber das ist ja auch
ein Großraumbüro, da ist das jetzt
manchmal ein bisschen nervig
für die Leute, aber bisher hat sich noch keiner
groß beschwert.
Habt ihr eine Tastatur mit Kabel oder Funk?
Also ich bin ja einer, der mag alles mit Kabel haben.
Mauskabel, Tastaturkabel.
Coolmaster MK850.
170 Euro, okay.
Das kostet genau das
Oh ne, die gefällt mir nicht.
Die gefällt mir nicht.
Die hat ja genau das gleiche Problem
wie die aktuelle Tastatur,
die ich hab. Das gefällt mir nicht.
Nein.
Garantiert nicht.
Ist dir das Layout egal?
Also es sollte schon ein
deutsches Tastaturlayout haben.
Und auch die ganzen Sondertasten
sollten da sein, wo sie sind.
Also hier Raute
und
Backslash
Corsair. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich
eine Corsair holen will.
Logitech E-Sports Challenger Edge Pro.
Was für ein Name.
Geh mal fort.
Logitech.
Ich würde mir
eine Ducky One Skyline holen. Ohne Scheiß.
Bei der weiß ich, dass sie was
taugt. Da habe ich schon jetzt über
ein Jahr auch Erfahrung mit gesammelt.
Das einzige, warum ich es mir halt nicht hole ist,
weil es keine gescheite Makrosoftware hat.
Machen wir es doch mal umgedreht.
Welche Hersteller haben gescheite
Makrosoftware?
Logitech weiß ich.
Dieses IQ ist
vorhanden.
So wirklich geil ist es nicht.
Razer hat irgendwie
Synapse Zeug. Das soll ganz gut
sein. Oh good.
Was? Glorious GMMK.
Echt?
Findest du die Corsair Makros gut?
Ich finde diese Software hier
eine übelste Zumutung eigentlich.
Guck dir das mal an.
Ich finde die Software ist eigentlich total die Zumutung.
Brauchst du
die Makros nur für deine Emotes? Na für meine
Emotes brauche ich das nicht.
Ich brauche die Makros zum Beispiel zum Switchen von
Desktops und 4M, dass das richtig funktioniert.
Also dass es noch einfacher, noch einfacher
funktioniert. Glorious
GMMK Full Size.
Kokona Build.
Huge.
Das ist die G513.
Warum ist die Benahmung
bei Logitech eigentlich so wirr?
Logitech hat gefühlt
jede Nummer mittlerweile
besetzt.
Das ist so billig.
Steelseries. Ja, ich kenne die Steelseries
Software nicht. Wenn du sagst, die ist gut.
Kann man sich das mal angucken.
Die haben nicht wirklich
Escape.
Das ist jetzt nicht
hier der Ernst, oder?
Die Escape Taste.
Oh.
Die Glorious
PC Gamer
Master Race Tastatur.
Was war Case King?
Aber das hat keine gescheite Makro
Software, oder?
Was ist denn zu billig für ein Kriterium?
Big Brain Kriterium.
Da fehlen die Tasten.
So ist
das keine Tastatur.
What?
Wie sind da keine Tasten dabei, oder was?
Ah, man kann sich das je nach Switches
kaufen. Okay.
Der Case King.
Das ist nicht der Laden, wo der Auer für arbeitet.
Wo wir immer
die Videos gucken.
Barebone, Barebone.
Der Tastaturkonfigurator.
Das wurde erste.
Ja, und wo kann man jetzt da
die Tasten auswählen?
Ich checke es irgendwie nicht.
Das ist mir zu Big Brain.
Ah, hier. Switch-Typ.
Boah.
Was ich, was ich da nehmen soll?
Clear Switches,
Green Switches, Blue Switches.
Das wäre schon wieder zu kompliziert.
Tastatur.
Black Box Switches, Brown Switches.
Warum gibt es da Brown Switches?
Und da Brown Switches?
Eieiei.
Ich würde mir sofort eine Ducky kaufen,
aber wegen der Makro-Software
kann ich mir keine kaufen.
Okay.
Das checke ich nicht.
Das ist mir zu
zu Big Brain,
das hier zusammenzuklicken.
Wie die Rabennudeln wegmachen.
Ah, ich weiß nicht, was soll ich mal kaufen?
Eigentlich am liebsten würde ich mal wieder so eine
kaufen.
Da weiß ich, dass es was taugt.
Das Ding ist richtig massiv und
ist eigentlich gut, aber die Makro-Software
sackt halt.
Häääh.
Wartet mal. Wie hieß dieses Ding?
USB...
USB
H...
H-Dings
hier. So.
Gibt es da vielleicht
irgendeinen Windows-Client, der checken kann,
welche Anwendung man drin ist?
Kann das Ding nicht, ne?
Aber wie gesagt, ich habe eh immer
einen Hinterkopf, immer ich habe Input-Lag, wenn ich da was dazwischenstöpsel.
Das kann ich nicht machen.
Eigene Makro-Software
bauen, das ist nicht so einfach, wie es aussieht.
Leute,
wenn noch einer Auto-Hotkey schreibt,
ey.
TKL-Double-Shot
Es gibt so viel.
Das überfordert mich voll.
Ne. Die hat man schon mal
anguckt. Ne. Die gefällt mir nicht,
weil abgerundete
Tasten hier unten.
Das mag ich gar nicht.
Was hast du für eine Maus? Dann kannst du alles
mit der Logitech-Maus.
Ich mache ja auch viel mit der Logitech-Software.
Aber ich kann ja
schlecht
Tasten auf der Tastatur mit was belegen,
die nicht von Logitech ist, mit der Logitech-Software.
Was?
Es gibt so 30 Milliarden
verschiedene Dinger.
Ne Klapperkiste, die gefällt
mir auch nicht. Die sieht genauso...
Es ist genau der gleiche Typ Tastatur,
die ich eigentlich loswerden will.
Logitech habe ich irgendwie, finde ich nix.
Was mir gefällt.
Von der Tastatur her.
Eigentlich will ich eine Ducky One Skyline
haben, mit
ordentlicher Makro-Software.
Ich meine, guckt euch mal diese Anleitung an,
wie das mit... Also die eingebaute
Makro-Funktion ist halt bissl, bissl
doof, ne.
Da musst du irgendwelche Jumper
auf der Rückseite machen und so.
Hast ihr denn schon mal Cherry-Tastatur?
Ne, aber die haben auch keine gescheite
Makro-Software und Cherry...
...Switches haben sie ja alle.
Wer braucht schon Makros in der
Tastatur? Tja...
Gibt's da vielleicht irgendwas zu, was einer schon
gebastelt hat? Was?
Ducky API...
Entschuldige, RGB-Lightning.
Ja gut, ich habe kein RGB.
Keylighting. Ich will mal Lighting. Ich will ordentliche Makros.
Das habe ich mir gerade
angeguckt, das Ding.
Ich war zu blöd, das zu konfigurieren.
Ich war zu doof, das ganze zu
konfigurieren.
Okay, gucken wir mal bei Amazon.
Warum hat das so schlechte Bewertungen?
Wie findest du die was? Die Logitech
Pro X. Hä?
Das ist ein Headset.
Eine Tastatur.
Moment, das ist auch eine Tastatur.
Logitech Benahmung.
Beste. Gibt's die auch mit NumBlock?
Gibt's die mit NumBlock?
NumBlock?
Ich will aber eine NumBlock.
Kann doch nicht so schwierig sein.
Ich will eine NumBlock,
eine ordentliche Makro-Software
und halt eine Tastatur, die einfach
Tastatur ist und funktioniert.
Wozu brauchst du eine NumBlock? Weil ich gerne
die NumBlock verwende.
Irgendwie ist das viel schwieriger, als ich gedacht habe.
Weil er ein Boomer ist.
Ich kann halt noch weiter gucken
als 15 cm zum Smartphone-Bildschirm.
Deswegen brauche ich auch
Big Brain-Funktionen in meiner Tastatur, die
Zoomer nicht brauchen.
Zum Beispiel ordentliche Makro-Software.
Lokalen Flohmarkt?
Okay, okay.
Surfjelly...
Da, meinste.
So, ich guck mir das jetzt an.
So.
Ascend. Wir ascenden erstmal.
Compact.
Das ist die Variante...
Das mag ich nicht.
The Keyboard.
Gibt's da ein Bild von der Makro-Software?
Aha.
Das ist schon mal
nicht das, was ich brauche.
Ich brauche eine Makro-Software, die auch
erkennt, was für eine Anwendung gerade aktiv ist.
So wie Logitech das mit den Profilen macht.
Ich seh's schon kommen.
Das wird wahrscheinlich...
Wahrscheinlich kaufe ich mir eine Logitech-Tastatur.
Auch wenn ich mit den Logitech-Tastaturen
irgendwie nicht so
warm werde.
Das ist echt kompliziert,
so eine Kack-Tastatur zu kaufen.
Sofort Software.
RGB 502 Carbon mit Numblock.
Also die Logitech-Produktbezeichnung.
Okay, das sieht wenigstens mal nach
einer Tastatur aus.
Einfach einer stinknormalen Tastatur.
Natürlich mit RGB.
Tasten sind ordentlich geformt.
Das Ding hat einen Numblock.
Das macht jetzt eigentlich erstmal
einen ganz passablen Eindruck.
Und die ist nicht so teuer.
Aber zu billig.
Ich muss ja das Gefühl haben, was Gutes zu kaufen.
Also ohne 150€ geht da nix.
Aber die macht echt einen guten Eindruck.
Die sieht einfach aus
wie eine Tastatur.
Was für Switches sind da drinnen?
Kann man das auswählen, was man da für...
Die Logitech-Bezeichnungen sind mir
zu...
zu big brain.
Ah, schön teuer. Das ist gut.
Ihh, flache Tasten.
Oh ne, keine flachen Tasten.
Kein Fall.
Ich weiß, ich bin da sehr wählerisch,
was das angeht. Aber hier finde ich nix.
Ich bin mir noch nicht mal sicher,
welche Switches haben wir denn, ehrlich gesagt.
Eigentlich finde ich diese MX-Speed-Switches
hier ganz gut.
Weil die sind...
Die sind nicht so laut.
Klar, darfst du.
Minus 380, bock.
Hier, Blue kann man auswählen.
Was?
Romer G Tactical Linear.
Ah, das ist dann
quasi so ein bisschen wie die Speed...
wie die Speed-Switches.
Leute, vielleicht mach ich's auch
einfach
viel zu kompliziert.
Vielleicht soll ich's...
Vielleicht mach ich's einfach viel zu kompliziert.
Also, Romer G.
Ne, G, G, was?
13. Ne, was denn jetzt?
13?
12?
Ich bin verwirrt.
Logitech.
Welche...
Und was ist der Unterschied hiervon?
Die hat doch auch nur einen Block.
Ist ne andere, seh ich.
Warum kann man die Switche nicht auswählen bei Amazon?
Handballenauflage bin ich mir
nur unschlüssig.
Da will ich mir wahrscheinlich was eigenes, was
du jetzt lächelst, kaufen.
Ja, dann vielleicht doch ne G513.
Linear waren die, die, die,
die leisen, oder?
Also,
139 Euro. Und die Logitech-Software
ist auch gut.
Warum eigentlich nicht?
Das macht doch eigentlich einen ganz passablen
Eindruck, das Ding.
Bei der hab ich gesagt, die ist
zu günstig.
Tja, das war ein Witz.
Lieferung bis Montag.
Ah, bis morgen geht nicht
mehr.
Ich hab ne Big Brain Idee.
Massive Brain.
Ich such einfach ne andere Tastatur, die morgen lieferbar ist.
Aber wahrscheinlich ist es zu spät.
Wahrscheinlich... Ne, es ist 21.20 Uhr.
Das funktioniert eh nicht mehr.
Da ist nix bis morgen lieferbar.
Ja, dann doch
Montag.
Ist aber vom Frame her wie deine.
Das ist ja nicht...
Achso.
Ah.
Ich seh es.
Aber die doch auch.
Ist doch überhaupt kein Unterschied, oder?
In mein lokales Geschäft.
Glaubst du nicht ernsthaft, dass ich in irgendeinen Saturn
gehe oder so und da was kaufe?
Also, erstens müsste ich da unter Menschen
gehen. Das ist ja schon mal
nicht auszudenken.
Und zweitens will ich dem Saturn
kein Geld geben.
Was der hauptsächliche Grund ist.
Warum tauchen Nachrichten von
SirCybot nicht im Stream auf?
Äh, gute Frage.
Bot im Namen.
Oh, stimmt!
Okay, dann ist das
ziemlicher Fail
von Steamlabs.
Also, ich muss euch jetzt ehrlich sagen.
Ich meine, ich checke null die Logitech-Benahmung.
Aber ich muss sagen,
das Ding hier macht doch eigentlich...
Das Teil macht doch eigentlich
nen ganz passablen Eindruck.
Die ordentliche Makro-Software.
Preis ist okay.
Die Tasten
sind nicht gebogen.
Nach außen gewölbt.
So rum.
Das hat nen Num-Block.
Ne, ne, ich hole deutsche Tastatur-Layout.
Alle Logitech-Tasten unter dem Link.
Okay.
Mediakeys brauche ich nicht.
Mediakeys ist wirklich so ein Ding,
habe ich überhaupt keine Verwendung für.
Zumal Mediakeys ja auch unter Windows kaputt sind, ne?
Guck mal.
Wenn ich sagen möchte hier
Pause.
Ah, jetzt funktioniert es. Okay.
Das geht nämlich manchmal nicht.
Pro X. Aber sagt doch mal ehrlich,
die Logitech-Benahmung ist doch nicht logisch, oder?
Oder vielleicht logisch,
weil man das irgendwie studiert hat.
Beleuchtung. Brauche ich nicht.
Tastatur-Typ.
Wired.
Serie ist mir auch egal. Tastatur-Typ.
Was ist denn?
Mech-Dome. Moment.
Ist...
Die ist doch auch Wired.
Warum taucht die jetzt hier nicht auf?
Ich habe gesagt mechanisch.
Und mit Kabel.
Warum taucht die hier jetzt nicht auf?
Die ist mechanisch und mit Kabel.
Hmm.
Wired.
Ach, wartet mal. Vorher war Wireless.
Oder?
Wobei ich doch Wired ausgewählt habe.
Die steht da wieder nicht drinnen.
Warum taucht die da nicht auf drinnen?
Die gibt doch überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Wired. Mechanisch.
Taut das Tastatur nicht auf.
Warum?
Egal. Ist ja auch egal.
Also ich finde, das Ding macht einen ganz guten Eindruck.
Oh, huge Video.
Ja, natürlich. Was sonst?
Moment, was? Was? Was?
Was fehlt da? Habe ich das jetzt nicht gesehen?
Das rechte Shift.
Ah!
Moment.
Was ist das? Was ist denn das für ein Crap?
Sehe ich ja jetzt erst.
Ne, Moment.
Das ist Ami-Layout.
Ähm, Kokona-Layout.
Ich muss mir das mal auf Deutsch angucken.
Ein Kurs. Hallo.
Kann ich mir das mal auf Deutsch einfach zeigen?
Ne.
Brauchen wir nicht.
Sagt der Amazon zu.
Ah, hier.
Das ist okay.
Was sagt hier?
Das US-Layout ist deutlich besser als das degenerierte deutsche System.
Das deutsche System ist nicht degeneriert.
Alle Programmiersprachen
wurden aber auf englischen Tastaturen erfunden.
Deswegen sind...
Ist das englische Layout zum Programmieren
eigentlich besser?
Einziges Problem ist, wenn man
ans deutsche Layout gewöhnt ist.
Ich finde, das lohnt sich nicht.
Man kann seine Zeit auch besser investieren.
Also, das Ding hier macht doch
einen passablen Eindruck.
Es hat eine gute Makro-Software.
Es hat einen Num-Block.
Es hat so das Tastatur-Layout,
was man haben will.
Normalerweise.
Ich glaube, das Ding probier ich mal aus.
Ich finde es auch gut.
Da ist auch eine Handballenablage
stand nämlich dabei,
nicht so ein komisches Plastik-Gummi-Ding
ist wie von der Corsair.
Ich glaube, das Ding bestell ich mir mal.
So, gibt es jetzt irgendwas, was ich vergessen habe?
Oder übersehen habe?
Was komplett gegen diese Tastatur spricht?
Glaube nicht, aber kann ja sein.
Ach, welche Switches? Ja, stimmt.
Ja, die hier.
Die, die nicht so einen Krach machen.
Muss man wissen, ob man die mag.
Ja, das kann man wahrscheinlich nur durch Ausprobieren rauskriegen.
Alter, dieses
Marketing-Geschwätz immer.
Hochwertiges Top Case
mit 505.2 Legierung
aus Flugzeug-Aluminium.
Ist Flugzeug-Aluminium irgendwie
kein Aluminium mehr?
Oder was?
Aufpassen, die gibt es auch günstiger.
Ja, ich sehe es gerade.
Muss mal gucken.
Du hast ja 50 Euro weniger.
Kosse.
Schon nie gehört.
Auch bei Amazon? Hä?
Ah, Moment.
Taktil, linear.
Ne, da sind wir wieder beim gleichen.
Neu und gebraucht ab
Monte Arenas.
Warum kostet das nur die Hälfte
wie bei Amazon?
Ah, gebraucht. Gebraucht.
Ach, gebraucht. Gehen wir fort.
Ne, das gibt es nicht.
Otto.
Deutscher Otto Lahn.
Ich dachte, du wolltest taktil.
Ich weiß nicht so genau, was ich wollte.
Die, die keinen Krach machen
und so ein bisschen wie die MX Speed
Switches sind.
Mediamarkt. Saturnee gehe ich nicht hin.
Ist die Handballenablage
abnehmbar?
Eine exzellente Big Brain
Frage.
Wahrscheinlich.
Sieht so aus, als wäre die einfach nur
angeklipst.
Also sprich, entweder
mit irgendwie einem Klettverschluss
oder so.
Ah, sind magnetisch. Okay.
Taktil ist ohne Krach mit
Feedback und linear ist ohne Krach.
Vielleicht will ich dann, wahrscheinlich will ich
dann tatsächlich taktil haben.
Prime. Gebraucht.
Nein, geh weg.
Gibt es nicht?
Ah, yes.
Zu begehrt die Tastatur.
Ah, okay.
Dann gucken wir mal bei Guides Hals nochmal.
Hatte man doch eben. Ach, Moment.
Dann habe ich mich
verguckt.
Euronics.
Wäre eigentlich vollkommen egal, wo ich das bestelle.
Okay, der Ladensack.
Da kann man nicht auswählen, was er für Switches haben will.
Das ist schon mal Müll.
Ne?
Ach so, Taktil. Naja.
Otto. Ich wusste gar nicht, dass es die noch gibt.
Magst du Saturn nicht? Ich mag
keinen Offline Laden.
Mag Leute nicht.
Saturn. Bei denen kaufe ich nichts.
Kackle an. Hallo?
She baited.
Was ist denn jetzt? Habe ich zu viele Tabs auf?
You got
she baited.
Ah, mein
Browser Extensions.
Blocken das Ganze.
PC Spezialist
Bonn. Aber ich glaube,
ich glaube, die kaufe ich mir.
Da weiß ich, dass die Makro
Software taugt und der Rest passt auch.
Und habt ihr mal keinen schönen, schnellen
ADAD Spam machen. Ich spiele zwar
kein Overwatch mehr, aber im Zweifelsfall will ich
schnellen ADAD Spam machen.
Wie ist denn so der Vergleich zwischen
vielleicht hat das hier
zwischen diesen Tasten
den MX Speed Tasten, die ich
jetzt habe und den MX
Brown, die ich auf der Arbeit habe.
Wie ist denn da so der Unterschied? Ich kann mir das immer schlecht
vorstellen.
Die Brown Switches, die ich auf der Arbeit
habe, die klicken schon. Ja, also
da hört man deutlich
deutlich Klick beim
runterdrücken. So, die MX
Speed hört man gar nicht. Guck, wenn ich
hier drücke, das juckt es
überhaupt nicht. Taktil sind
wie du auf der Arbeit hast.
Aber ich hätte gerne lieber wieder welche, die wie
MX Speed sind. Also muss ich doch linear
nehmen, oder was?
Dann bestelle ich die jetzt so.
Eats. Bam.
Also jetzt nicht im Stream, weil da muss ich mal ein Zeug eingeben.
Linear ist aber nicht
taktil. Ich weiß, dass das
nicht taktil ist, aber
ich habe keine Ahnung, was ich haben will. Deswegen kann ich nicht
sagen, ich will taktil oder ich will das.
Ich hätte gerne wieder so
von Empfehlungen her, so was wie die MX Speed
Dinger, die ich daheim habe.
Zum Schreiben macht es mir zwar auf der Ducky One
auf der Arbeit mehr Spaß, aber
äh, sagen wir mal so, Krach
Gaming plus
Schreiben, so die Kombination ist glaube ich
das nicht verkehrt. Wisst ihr
was, Leute? Ich bestelle mir das Teil jetzt einfach.
Und guckt mal, wie das ist.
Ich bestelle mir das einfach und guckt, wie
das ist. Und jetzt
zum Abschluss, oder ich weiß nicht, ob
wir fertig sind, mal gucken. Äh,
jetzt gucken wir noch
ein Video. Und zwar habe ich gesehen,
dass es
neue LoRa Boards gibt.
Wahrscheinlich war
irgendjemand bei dem Stream dabei,
wo ich
den
Controller programmieren wollte
für das Grab von meinem Opa.
Kann sich da noch jemand dran erinnern?
Wahrscheinlich denken sich jetzt alle
Leute so, alter Max, was, was,
was willst du? Also,
ich habe ja mal vor einer Weile einen Stream
gemacht, wo ich einen ESP32
programmiert habe, mit
ähm,
Bodenfeuchtigkeitssensor
und Idle,
niedrigem Idle Stromverbrauch.
Kann sich vielleicht auch der ein oder andere
dran erinnern. Und
das habe ich damals gemacht
mit
einem,
mit so einem Board, mit so einem
Controller und
einem
Moisture Sensor.
Muss man immer gucken, was man da eintippt.
Mit so einem Ding.
So, und Ziel
des Ganzen ist ja gewesen,
dass ich das quasi
mit einem LoRa Chip quasi
in das Grab von meinem, also
in die Erde
äh, auf dem Friedhof stecke,
wo das Grab von Opa und Oma ist
und ich dann quasi mir
per LoRa übertragen lassen kann,
also Smart Grave quasi,
per LoRa dann übertragen
lassen kann, wie die Bodenfeuchtigkeit
auf dem Friedhof ist, dass ich weiß,
wann ich gießen gehen muss.
Vielleicht erinnert sich der ein oder andere noch dran.
Das Projekt
ist ja nie
fertig geworden. Ähm,
das Projekt ist ja nie fertig geworden, aber
es gibt jetzt neue LoRa Boards.
Und da habe ich gesehen,
da hat einer meiner
Lieblingstechnik YouTube Channels
und der
meint mit Technik auch wirklich Technik,
ein Video zu gemacht.
Deswegen wollte ich mir mal das Video angucken
zu den neuen LoRa Boards.
Und wir gucken gleich mal bei AliExpress,
was der Kram kostet.
AliExpress Gif.
Äh, das sind die alten
Boards.
Ah, hier.
Genau.
So eins will ich haben.
Hast du schon geguckt?
Halra?
Ja, aber das Board finde ich interessant.
Der Chip und das Board
hat glaube ich einen ziemlich
geringen Idle-Verbrauch.
Was es natürlich für Batterieanwendungen gut macht.
Aber ich will mal gucken,
was er dazu sagt.
Ich finde es cool, dass ich nicht der Einzige bin,
der den Guy with a Swiss
Accent guckt.
Was ist denn das für ein Zäpfchen?
Sieht aus wie ein Zäpfchen, oder?
Was? Was ist das?
Eine waterproofed
Probe? Was?
Okay, es ist wasserdicht.
Wie funktioniert das mit dem Board?
Kannst du das grob zusammenfassen?
Naja, also, so wie es geplant war und so wie es auch funktioniert hat.
Also der Friedhof ist
ungefähr 1,2 Kilometer weg.
Das heißt, wenn ich mit einem
Board, wenn ich quasi mit irgendwas
kommunizieren will, was 1,2
Kilometer weg ist,
ähm,
fällt WLAN schon mal
logischerweise raus.
Also WLAN ist dafür nicht geeignet.
Und,
es gibt eigentlich nur zwei Möglichkeiten.
Entweder, man macht das mit Mobilfunk,
aber Mobilfunk kostet
und Mobilfunk ist auch nicht so easy,
da einen ESP anzuschließen.
Ähm, oder aber,
man sucht sich was anderes als WLAN
und da gibt es LoRa.
LoRa ist quasi ein Protokoll, was
ganz, ganz geringe Bandbreite
hat, dafür
eine ziemlich hohe Reichweite.
Und ich habe es ausprobiert,
ich komme
von mir daheim,
1,2 Kilometer
auf den Friedhof
und wenn ich das Ding
auf das Grab lege,
ich habe doch sogar ein Foto von gemacht, oder?
Ich habe da doch sogar ein Foto
von
gemacht. Fotos.
Ich poste immer so viele Fotos, da findet man jetzt wahrscheinlich
nichts.
Das war letzt Jahr, irgendwann.
Nicht so, Max, Max.
PS Friedhof.
Äh, Friedhof?
Grab?
Okay, keine Ahnung, ich finde es jetzt nicht.
Zumindest habe ich dann
hier unterm Dach einen Controller stehen
mit Antenne und auf
am Grab habe ich dann
einen Sensor mit Bodenfeuchtigkeit
und so einem Controller
und der schickt quasi dann alle
alle vier Stunden
die Bodenfeuchtigkeit vom Friedhof zu mir heim.
In dem Bereich gibt es aber
Lora ist 800...
868, doch, doch.
Das kann man verwenden, überhaupt kein Ding.
Megahertz.
Ich glaube in der EU kann man auch 433 verwenden.
Ich habe ein paar Lora Module ausprobiert.
433 und 868.
Das hier ist glaube ich
für Asien.
Ähm...
Bei mir funktioniert 868
besser, wobei theoretisch ja
433 besser durch
Mauern gehen müsste, aber
868 funktioniert
bei mir am besten.
Und wenn ich sage, das Ding hat langsame
Datenübertragungsraten,
das hat wirklich langsame Datenübertragungsraten.
Ja, das betreibe ich
da mit einem Akku. Ich habe es aber nie
final getestet,
das was ich getestet habe,
ich habe es bei mir im Hof
in der Erde verbuddelt
und dort Sachen senden lassen.
Ähm... Ach, der Akku hängt da.
Der Akku hält eine ganze Weile.
Ich kann dir sagen, wie lange
der Akku hält. Ähm...
Battery Calculator.
So, machen wir mal 2 Sekunden.
Code Execution, Sleep Time.
Ähm...
Was sind das? Sleep Time, Sekunden.
Äh...
Seconds, 4 Stunden
zu Sekunden.
So...
Äh... Power Consumption
during Code Execution.
Weiß ich nicht, irgendwie so.
Ähm... In Sleep Mode haben wir
Micro Ampere, ich sag jetzt mal
so 9 ungefähr.
Äh... 1.200er Akku
und machen wir hier 20.
So.
Das ist Optimalwerte,
das stimmt hinten und vorne nicht.
Aber so ungefähr kann man sich das Ganze
vorstellen. Also die Batterie wird
dann ungefähr so...
sagen wir mal 2-3 Jahre halten.
Eher... sagen wir mal so, wenn es ein Jahr
hält, bin ich schon froh.
Ne, ich denke mal in einem Jahr wird es ungefähr halten.
Ich denke mal ungefähr in einem Jahr wird
die Batterie halten, wenn alles gut läuft.
Was für eine Batterie
ist das? Ne...
So eine ganz normale... So eine!
Sowas da. Ich habe es mir mit Solarzellen
überlegt, aber
Solarzellen ist nun mal eine ganz eigene Herausforderung.
Zumal die Solarzellen irgendwohin müssen und ich will keine
so... Ich will ja, dass man an dem Grab nichts sieht.
Erstens, weil dann sogar da
Leute was klauen und zweitens,
weil es halt auch nicht schön aussieht, wenn da eine Solarzelle
auf dem Grab liegt.
Ich meine, es wäre advanced,
ja, aber
es sieht ein bisschen doof aus, wenn auf dem Grab eine Solarzelle
liegt, zumal das wasche garantiert
jemand klaut. Mittlerweile
wird sogar auf dem Friedhof Zeug geklaut.
Gießkannen haben sie mir schon geklaut.
Auf dem Friedhof.
Und wahrscheinlich striker regt sich da auch jemand
auf. Warum man das auf dem Grab
haben muss, habe ich doch gerade gesagt,
dass man die Bodenfeuchtigkeit,
die... die... ähm...
wie viel Wasser im Boden ist,
übertragen kann. Dass ich weiß,
wann ich wieder gießen gehen muss.
Das ist eigentlich ziemlich Big Brain.
Ich guck danach,
wie die Bodenfeuchtigkeit ist.
Wenn die Bodenfeuchtigkeit quasi
unter einem gewissen Level ist. Ich könnte es ja
noch mehr Big Brain machen. Ich habe ja
so die... Ich habe ja gar nicht so die...
ähm...
komplette High IQ
Sache programmiert.
Ich hätte es ja auch so machen können, dass das Ding
nur den...
also dass das Ding alle vier
Stunden aufwacht aus dem Deep Sleep.
Luft... äh Boden... doch hab ich,
hab ich gemacht. Hab ich gemacht.
Ähm... Bodenfeuchtigkeit
Mist. Und erst
wenn die Abweichung
größer ist und unter einem gewissen
Wert, nur dann schickt
er was. Was nämlich dazu führt,
dass der Energieverbrauch noch viel
geringer ist. Weil das einzige,
wo das Ding richtig viel Energie verbraucht,
ist wenn er die Sachen schickt.
Ähm... passt... passt in dieses Ding
das Board rein oder was
soll das sein, wenn es fertig ist?
Das ist einfach nur eine Kapsel, wo man
einen Sensor reinmachen kann. Ja gut.
Ähm... das brauche ich nicht
wirklich. Max FPS
Status. Hast du meinen Tweet gefunden?
Ne.
Das ist das falsche.
Das ist, wo ich ein bisschen mit
ESP Now rumgespielt habe.
Aber so ungefähr zu dieser Zeit müsste
das gewesen sein, wo ich das mit dem Friedhof
gepostet habe. Aber musste es jetzt nicht
suchen.
So. Und da gibt es jetzt
neue Boards, die wohl ziemlich gut
sein sollen. Deswegen wollte ich mir das Video mal angucken von ihm,
was er dazu so
zu erzählen hat.
Das erinnert mich immer an so...
Mit dem zweiten sieht man besser.
Ich will eigentlich nur Stromverbrauch
wissen. Also was macht er?
New and old Chips. Ganz ehrlich,
solange die neuen nicht schlechter sind als die alten,
juckt mich das nicht.
Ähm...
Modules.
Arduino IDE Support ist mir auch
relativ egal.
Man kriegt es schon garantiert.
Man kriegt es irgendwie zum Laufen.
Hier. Power.
Power Consumption.
Output während er überträgt ist nicht so wichtig,
weil das Übertragen dauert
zwei Sekunden oder so.
Ähm...
Power Consumption.
Das habe ich doch nicht bestellt. Ne.
Zeig mal Power Consumption.
Wir gucken das gar nicht in Einskomfort.
Wir springen vor zu Power Consumption.
Ah, hier.
Power Consumption of the board.
Is it okay for battery operation?
We know from many other
boards that power consumption,
especially for development boards
like this one, is not suitable...
Ja, weil die Hersteller low brain sind
und immer den USB-Anschluss nicht abschalten.
...operation.
According to the data sheet, this board
hat sogar einen Solar-Input.
Oh, guck mal.
Das hat sogar einen Solar-Input.
Das ist ein cooles Board.
Und wo macht man die Batterie dran?
Hat das einen Anschluss für eine Batterie?
Ist das ein Batterieanschluss?
Ich sehe jetzt keinen, wenn ich ehrlich bin.
Aber vielleicht unten.
Ach, da!
Ah, hätte ich mal gewartet.
Da zeigt das ja.
Was es einem bringt,
dass ich weiß, wann ich gießen gehen muss.
...charge Li-Ion-Batterie
at 3.7 Volts
and use the LoRa-Band.
I use my OT
to measure the current.
The board sleeps for a certain period,
wakes up, sends a LoRa-Message,
waits for confirmation
and goes to sleep again.
If we zoom in, we see that the transmitter
consumes the expected 87 mA.
Fortunately, only for less than 100 ms.
Ja, das...
Der Verbrauch ist wurscht.
Ich brauche...
Ich muss wissen, was das Ding idle verbraucht.
...160 ms,
where it consumes around 10 mA.
Overall it consumes for 1.16 seconds
an average of 4.75 mA,
which leads to 5.5 mA.
Steckt der Chip direkt in der Erde?
Nee, in einer IP67-Box.
Das Einzige, was direkt im Boden steckt,
ist der Sensor.
Ja, das ist mir egal.
Was ist der idle Verbrauch?
Was?
9.6 mA...
Also 10 mA.
Oh, das ist richtig gut!
Das ist fast so wenig...
Das ist genauso wenig,
wie der Fire Beetle Verbrauch.
Das ist richtig gut.
10 mA, das ist nix.
Der hält das Ding locker,
denn ja, an der Batterie.
an der Batterie.
Ja,
das ist richtig gut.
Ja, das ist richtig gut.
OK, bestellen muss ich auch noch.
Ok, bestellen muss ich auch noch.
Ok, diese komische Sensorpille,
Sensor-Zäpfchen brauch ich nicht.
Ein Jahr, locker hält das Ding ja,
an der 1200...
an so einem Ding da.
Ist ein Raspberry Pi Zero
nicht billiger?
Raspberry Pi Zero ist
Zero ist, ähm, ich glaube
ähnlich
ähnlich teuer, aber
ne, teurer,
aber nicht wirklich viel, aber
hat riesen Nachteile
gegenüber, ähm,
gegenüber so einem ESP32.
Der Stromverbrauch
ist einfach, vor allem Idle, einfach
viel, viel geringer.
So ein Raspberry Pi
kannst du vielleicht, äh,
sagen wir mal so, kannst, ich, ich, ich schätze,
ich, ich, ist über den Daumen gepeilt, ja,
über den Daumen gepeilt. Sag ich mal so,
sag ich mal ungefähr, kannst du so ein Raspberry,
kannst du an so einem Ding
5, 6 Stunden betreiben,
wahrscheinlich länger,
ich sag jetzt einfach mal, sag mal, sag mal,
10 Stunden, 10 Stunden,
einfach, oder 5, 6, 7, 8, schwierig zu
schätzen, aber, sagen wir, runden
wir mal auf, sagen wir, du kannst so einen Raspberry
einen Tag, oder vielleicht sogar
zwei Tage an so einer Batterie betreiben,
ähm, ich weiß nicht, was da so
standardmäßig Idle braucht, aber dann
ist Schluss.
Ähm,
wohingegen, du einen,
äh,
einen ESP,
in dem Fall einen ESP32,
ähm, wenn der
ordentlich gebaut ist, das Board,
sodass der in Deep Sleep gehen kann,
und dann alles ausschaltet, mal
ein Jahr an der Batterie hängen lassen kannst.
Wie ist eben der andere
YouTube-Channel, Andreas Spieß,
heißt der, also,
ein Raspberry Pi und sowohl
der Zero, das sind beides
tolle Geräte für die, für
ihren Anwendungszweck, aber
für, ähm, Batteriebetrieb
sind die beide nix.
So, so ein Ding muss ich mir bestellen.
Was kostet denn hier das Board jetzt?
365?
Das, das, das
check ich immer bei AliExpress nicht.
Kostet, kostet
die Kapsel, kostet
die Kapsel jetzt 15 Euro,
oder was?
What? Ich will eigentlich, will ich das
Board haben.
Ah, hier ist das Board.
13,70.
Was ist unsere Empfehlung
für Sie?
Äh, äh,
alter, AliExpress, mach's doch nicht so
kompliziert. Ich brauch nicht
863 bis 915,
ich brauch 868
Megahertz, nicht irgendwie random
irgendwas. Hallo?
Was? Ich brauch,
äh, AliExpress, please.
Come on, bra.
Ah, der kann bestimmt,
der kann bestimmt beide.
Da hab ich so meine Zweifel.
Die können eigentlich nicht beide.
Zumindest konnten die alten Chips
nicht. Da hab ich so meine
Zweifel, weil ja auch die ganze Antennengeschichte
und so, also
entweder haben die einfach den gleichen Chip
zweimal reingebaut.
Farbe?
Wo steht Farbe? Ich seh keine Farbe.
Und warum,
warum kann man das überhaupt hier nochmal auswählen?
Ja, vielleicht kann der wirklich beides.
Vielleicht kann der echt beides.
Verwirrt mich,
dass es hier zweimal das gleiche
gibt.
ASR 650,
ASR
6000,
ach Gott, die Bezeichnung
wieder.
Vor allem, warum heißt das den XSX
1262?
Oh, der alte hieß
SX1272,
SX1272.
Was, Farbe?
Ach hier, ja ich weiß, das sind die einzelnen
Sachen, die hier drin sind.
Ist mir schon klar.
Da kannst du, ne, also die sind die ganzen unterschiedlichen Artikel.
Das verwirrt mich mal wieder
bei AliExpress.
Also ich vermute mal, dass ich den da haben will.
Was sich preislich
zwar nicht so ganz deckt,
aber ich ehrlich gesagt auch nicht so checke, wo da jetzt
der Unterschied ist.
Devboard 433, Devboard 868
und das ist
okay, Leute, AliExpress,
was auch immer.
Aber so ein Teil werde ich mir
auf jeden Fall noch bestellen.
Das ist sehr nice. Da kann ich endlich mal
mein Smartgrave-Projekt abschließen.
Wozu ich mir jetzt allerdings für
15 Euro so ein
Zäpfchen kaufen soll, erschließt
sich mir überhaupt nicht.
Ist das groß genug,
dass hier auch der Controller reinpasst?
Oder passt hier nur
oder passt hier nur,
der LoRa-Sensor rein?
Also die AliExpress-Bilder
sind wieder absolut big brain, muss man sagen.
Huge brain.
Das muss ich mir mal in Ruhe angucken, bevor ich da was
bestelle, sonst ist es wieder rip.
Das ist der gleiche Shop,
beides.
Hau mal den Darkreader rein.
Das ist ja die hässlichste LoRa-Antenne
je, ever.
Naja, wurscht. Das gucke ich mir mal in Ruhe an.
Aber da muss man halt...
Wann ist es lieferbar? 23.01.
23.01.
Was haben wir ansonsten noch so für Sachen?
DHL.
24 Euro.
Mhm, ist klar.
E-Paket mit Tracking-Number.
AliExpress Premium Shipping.
Einfach für 19 Euro.
Vielleicht ist der Controller dabei.
Das ist halt echt...
Ich hab's auch gesehen,
aber ich glaube nicht, dass der Controller
dabei ist. Ich glaube,
bei der Kapsel ist nur
der LoRa-Chip dabei.
Also nur der da.
Oder was auch immer.
Ich check's, ehrlich gesagt,
grad nicht so genau.
Aber werde ich mir bestellen.
Jutsch.
Little Honey Play With Baby.
Ja, Play With Baby
ist eindeutig so eine Metallspinne.
Ist schon das Beste für...
um mit Babys zu spielen, oder?
So eine Metallspinne.
Little Honey, so ein Metallskorpion.
Nicht Chinesen, oder?
E-Sports!
Oh, wir gucken mal, was es bei AliExpress unter E-Sports gibt.
Das ist jetzt E-Sports?
Ein LoRa-Gateway.
Hohe Qualität,
stillruhige 120mm PC-Fan.
Batterien,
Abdichtungskabel-Abdichtungsdinger,
Controller-Ladegerät-Dock.
Das ist ja richtig E-Sports.
Moment.
Wie viel kostet der Lüfter?
Wartet mal.
Ah, das ist G-Bait.
Das ist G-Bait.
Das ist Lock-Angebot,
dass man sich neu registriert.
Das ist G-Bait.
Sobald ich mich einlocke, geht das nicht mehr.
Komplett G-Bait.
Also man muss schon sagen,
es ist äußerst E-Sport-mäßig,
was man hier bei AliExpress unter E-Sport kaufen kann.
Es ist auch übrigens keine Switch,
sondern nur eine Hülle.
Oh Leute, 22 Uhr.
Oh.
Es pennt.
Aber AliExpress ist immer so schön billig alles.
Und ich habe schon lange nichts mehr bei AliExpress bestellt.
Es wird mal wieder Zeit.
Das ist wieder so ein 1-Cent-Ding.
Top-Cac.
Guck mal hier.
Top-Cac-USB-Halter.
Doch, das ist E-Sports, wenn man da draufklickt.
Guckt hier.
E-Sports.
Das ist der typische AliExpress-G-Bait.
Da haben selten Sachen was mit dem zu tun,
wo man draufklickt.
Das ist normal.
AliExpress, das ist G-Bait in Perfektion an vielen Stellen.
Die schreiben immer andere Sachen hin, als dann dahinter ist.
Die schreiben das hin, was dich dazu bringt, draufzuklicken.
Ich meine, sonderlich E-Sport ist das Ganze jetzt ja nicht.
Das ist eher abhängig von dem, was ich mir schon angeguckt habe.
Eatshare.
Braucht für seine PlayStation 5 einen extra Fan, okay.
Ugreen.
Das ist alles reichlich sinnloses Zeug, was man da kaufen kann.
Ganz viele Kabel-Abdichtungs-Dinger.
Also jede Menge Lampenhalterungen,
beziehungsweise Mikrofon- und Pop-Schutzhalterungen.
HDMI-Kabel.
Controller-Ladestationen.
Batterien.
Und Zeug, was ich nicht brauche.
Oh, Huge-USB-Sticks, Leute. Da sind sie wieder.
Ich suche heute nicht nach Huge-USB-Sticks.
Kein Bock auf Bonkertos.
Würdest du mir VSCode für Flutter empfehlen?
Hatte bis jetzt immer Software von VSCode.
Ich kann dir zu Flutter nichts empfehlen, weil ich Flutter selbst nur ganz wenig verwendet habe.
Ich weiß nicht, was die beste Idee für Flutter ist.
Weil wenn man nach Huge-USB-Sticks ist, man irgendwelche Sex-Spielzeuge findet bei AliExpress.
Was auch immer das mit USB-Sticks zu tun hat, das weiß nur AliExpress.
Der Schneemann-CPU-Cooler.
Ah, der ist es also.
So der chinesische Noctua-Fake.
Was die mir hier alles andrehen wollen.
Also, dass ich Kabeldichtung brauche, scheint ganz hoch im Kurs zu stehen.
Ich brauche unbedingt Kabeldichtung.
Ganz unterwichtig.
Kabeldichtung brauche ich unbedingt.
Ganz, ganz, ganz, ganz, ganz, ganz wichtig.
Wie viele Kabel ich abdichten muss, das könnt ihr euch gar nicht vorstellen.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Was meint ihr, wie viele Kabel ich habe?
Max, ich hoffe, dass morgen die Streams besser laufen beim 36.
Äh, liefen die heute schlecht?
Äh, Internet-Streams?
Kelly J. würde ich nehmen.
Vor allem, wenn du schon immer Jet-Planes-Zeug verwendet hast.
Schlecht bist gar nicht.
Na gut, da gucken wir...
Also den WOT gucken wir uns auf jeden Fall an, vom Bahn-Mining.
Den WOT gucken wir uns an.
Den Vortrag bin ich wirklich sehr gespannt.
Bester Treffer.
Für was bester Treffer?
Für...
Bikinis.
Wo kann man die CCC-Geschichten sehen?
Einfach bei denen auf der Seite.
Muss mal Google anschmeißen.
Ist die mir wieder verzeugt?
Ich glaube, dass die mich verkaufen wollen bei AliExpress, der Wahnsinn.
Ich scroll hier besser nicht so weit.
Man weiß nie, was da drin ist.
Okay, Leute.
Ich gehe jetzt pennen.
Zumindest gehe ich off.
Äh, warum habe ich das immer noch auf?
Gibt es morgen Aufwach-Stream?
Keine Ahnung.
Weiß ich nicht.
Muss ich mal morgen früh gucken.
Kann ich dir nicht sagen.
Moin, Alex.
Du bist leider ein bisschen spät.
Also, Leute.
Rush B. Wir sehen uns morgen.
Bis dann. Macht's gut.
See you.